um well let me let me just restate that
so plaintiffs 1 through 32 are received
plane is 34 through 38 are received
plainus 40 is received and planus 44 is
received so that excludes the Fong
records 33 and it excludes the exhibit
39 which is which may be introduced
later
does that sound correct
43 I can only use it during 43 is a
demonstrative exhibit that you could use
during closing
is already out they've they've withdrawn
33.
are there fmri references in 34 also
I don't believe so I mean there may be
references to
the doctor confident in that MRI but it
doesn't have Dr Thomas
Samurai
evaluation I don't believe but okay so
the court will receive plaintiffs 1-32
34-38
40 and 44. as exhibits yes
all right turning now to this proposed
order I haven't read the proposed orders
there is there an issue with the
proposed order or an objection to it
on the animations
ago
your honor we uh it's our understanding
that the court directed us to
wait until trial to see what the
evidence shows and then we can object
just before they're admitted the
animations are admitted but we do find
them objectionable now and we don't want
to waive that objection and have them
just pop up on the screen
as I
recall from your instruction after the
evidentiary hearing sure sure I have a
physical copy if you want one
no I've got it here thank you
are there any objections to the proposed
order
um which doesn't
address the issues that you just raised
Mr Bueller
the animation's up before they're
admitted
there has to be a sponsoring Witness
ES
the top four lines
we don't recall that being part of the
decision
the H3 top four lines
yeah I re-listened this morning before
we started and I didn't hear that part
in there in my oral ruling then that's
my mistake
and I'll probably add a little bit more
what I'll be adding is um
find my notes
quite yet
Mr Bure
he also specified in the hearing what
the uh witness the defense would have to
do to the sponsoring witness we have to
testify before it would be admitted
so I I may edit more details but this is
what I would include something from
these lines there must be evidence to
support the claim the that and animation
accurately reflects a witness testimony
and it made uncontested facts
that but the ultimate test the court
will apply is does the animation active
accurately reflect the witness's
testimony
so it doesn't have to it's not that what
happened it's doesn't demonstrative of a
witness's testimony
the owner just mentioned or should be in
order
to take a look at it but yeah this made
some notice this morning I went back and
listened to the web hearing on it
I will insert is the jury all assembled
foreign
okay the jury's not quite all assembled
yet so let's take a short process while
we wait for the jury to be completely
assembled
but it's not a big one okay so
we produce a poor quality screenshot of
um
texts right after when I said that guy
kind of hurt me and a high quality now
and so
exhibits
we will give them a copy thank you and
then also
um I'd like to have a jury instruction
conference tomorrow
um I need you to tell me one if it'd be
better to have it at lunch or at the end
of the day tomorrow so think about that
talks amongst yourselves and get back to
me
thank you
uh we might need to deal with that jury
instruction issue if they're coming out
right now
which jury instruction issue thank you
sorry to be vague
with the newly disclosed comments
section if they're going to use that
with Terry then I would like the
instruction read that this came through
defense Council your honor just to let
me replace defense counsel this and and
the clerk that we're going to call Craig
Ramon five minutes to do the
confirmation of them
comments exhibit 44. okay and can I see
the stipulated statement that the
instruction that the court will be
giving the very concerning exhibit 44.
have that drafted or printed out but it
was the neutral statement that
Norman mentioned
specific language if there's an
agreement as I'll just do my own yeah
what you said orally you know 15 minutes
ago was fine
what's in your in your filing
but I'll have to go through the language
and make a decision
right so uh
should we uh
hand write it because we won't be able
to print somebody now since we last met
you know
minutes ago
we handed you the paragraph We want
what I've got here yeah
well the last part of the last sentence
that were previously unavailable to
either party
I think
is
exhibit 44 was found
by a
third party
and both parties are
agreeing that
this is an authentic copy of what was
found
and then Craig bone who we're going to
call it now will
go through that and confirm his comments
about three minutes
I think I've got enough I can probably
craft something right here
and if you want to be heard I'm
I'm going to talk I think I know all
your arguments thank you
foreign
so I think what I'm going to do is is I
will read something on the Fly
and I'm going to ask that the parties
and Council not embellish any of the
facts concerning what I'm about to read
to the jury okay
no one do you agree okay
we're ready for the jury
foreign
all right
good morning members of the jury
I pray that you're traveling in this
morning was safe and
everyone got here okay
um
the the weather outside is still winter
I guess
well there is a new piece of evidence in
this case
I'm going to tell you about that
a viewer that's been following this
trial out of the courtroom
and familiar with finding archived
website links investigated the link
referenced on defendants exhibit 102.
that's the Mr Sanderson email to his
daughters on the day of the accident
there's a there's a link at the bottom
of that page well this viewer through
their efforts and expertise through
through that we now have a copy of what
was contained in that link
and you will receive it it is going to
be an exhibit it's plaintiff's exhibit
44 and defendants exhibit 102.
plaintiff's exhibit 44 and defendants
exhibit 102 and the parties do agree
that this new exhibit is authentic
complaint if you may proceed
thank you your honor plain of Terry
Sanderson calls or recalls Craig Ramon
Mr Ramon you'll need to be sworn in
again as a witness it's a new day
right up here sir
hello
um do you solemnly swear the testimony
you are about to give in the matter
before the court to be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth so
help you God
thank you
good morning
good morning Mr Ramon good morning
I've handed you a plaintiff's exhibit
44.
have you had a chance to review that
before
yes
and this uh is are the comments
and postings on Meetup Meetup
.com is that correct yes
and this was the
website that you use to meet up with
the other skiers on the day of the crash
correct yes
and first I'd like to turn you to page
two of exhibit 44 plaintiff's exhibit
44.
and on the lower left you see the color
photograph of the woman smiling yes is
that the ski patroller that you met on
the day of the crash
okay you have it on page two
uh
oh yes that's
true that's Whitney Smith that you met
that day yes oh show it sorry
you see on the lower left of uh exhibit
uh 44 page two yes okay
and you made a few postings on this
meetup.com website correct yes okay
I'm going to read some of the your
postings
on that day and so I'm going to
reference some of the pages
can you turn to page four of Nine the
page numbers are on the bottom right
do you see page four of no nine four
years okay
there's
okay
your first comment on that page four I'm
just going to read it to you and ask you
to confirm that this is what you uh
posted
but before we start that you'll see it
says
2588 days ago
yes I see that
and this was probably before this key
crash
but on the same day correct
it's I'm not I'm not sure okay so I'm
sitting I'm I'm guessing there's
probably
um it was it was right around
oh which which one you're talking about
I'm sorry the one in the middle of the
page
um I'll just
yeah just give your Valley your paths
yes that's okay that's true you you
wrote or typed in that day just give
Dear Valley your past they have your
photo it will be a great day I will be
on the hill at 9 30. that's uh your
first posting that day you believe
yes okay and then at the bottom
of the page four
you have another post
well maybe
um
well let's see I guess that one's uh
a different one maybe let's see
oh
maybe that's a different day
uh I'm gonna move to the the next one
the uh
let's go to page
six of nine can you go there
okay I'm going to read just what you
typed in there in the middle
says Scott Terry was not doing the man
thing
Terry had a bad hit to the head you do
not have the ski patrol take you down
the hill if you have a pain in your ass
is that what you typed that day yes it
is this is the day of the crash
this was a few days after
okay
then at the bottom of that page six and
we're going to continue to seven it has
your name and then it continues on to
page seven
I'm going to read you what page seven
says
Scott the thing you did not see was
Terry was knocked out cold
bad hit to the Head not not too sure if
Terry has broken ribs I did see the
Terry did not know his name
I asked Terry what his name was and he
did not know
Scott it scared the hell out of me is is
that what you typed it
true
that was on or around the day of the
crash or after the crash that was a
little bit after a few days after the
crash okay
then at the bottom of page seven
we have another comment
do you see that
yeah yes I do
and uh you typed Scott thanks for the
humor I got it when you were trying to
make light of the whole thing you guys
did not see what I did see
no need to say you're sorry you typed
that correct yes I did
then the final page page eight of nine
and under your name it says you cannot
make this up Gwyneth took out Terry last
week last Saturday her son broke his arm
skiing at Park City
Gwyneth was staying at the Montage she
took her plane out of millionaire
airport I wish I did know so many people
what makes me mad is that Gwyneth took
out Terry and just took off is that what
you typed that yeah it was the week
after the crash yes it is
okay and uh
except for the uh
you know irrelevant stuff at the end on
page nine uh that's all I have
who is very tea in exhibit 44 Plato's
exhibit Terry T has mentioned
do you remember
um
I'm not sure who Verity is
could it be Terry Sanderson
and
um why don't you look at the very T
comments and see if
go ahead and ask your next question yeah
um
that's right
okay Craig would you go to page two of
this exhibit 44.
okay
on the left it says Verity event
organizer
you see that yes I do well so two over
it says curl event organizer for shared
groups
you see that yes I do
was Kurt L at the Meetup group at Deer
Valley on the day of the crash
yeah Kurt was the one who organized that
day okay go back to the left
and look at very T are you able to
recognize the photo
above very T it looks like it looks like
Terry and Terry was the one who
organized the uh this the meetup groups
up at Alto okay
that's all I have thank you Craig
thank you Mr Bueller Mr Egan
thank you your honor
Mr Ramon good to see you again
I have a couple questions from the
defense
um
so
the first would be at the start of this
page
and I haven't used this Elmo projector
before so give me a second
do you see do you see that that uh
on page two
got it thank you I have to press Focus
okay there you are so you see that
there's some photos there at the bottom
of the page
yes and do you recognize the the photo
there
of the ski patroller
yes was that Whitney Smith
I believe so the ski patroller who
responded to Mr Sanderson on the hill
yes and uh and cared for him during the
urgent care or the first aid clinic
visit that he had there on the skilly
ski hill yes
and uh I do not see any videos there
were there any to your memory GoPro or
other videos posted on this webpage no
and then
um
and and I believe uh you're unaware of
any GoPro footage at all is that correct
yes
and then if you go to page
let's match it up with mine here
page seven
um
actually your name is cut off at the top
there so if you look back at page six
can you see that it shows your name
and then goes on to page seven where
there's at the very top there uh note
that you wrote is that right yes okay
and in that note you write Terry did not
know his name
I asked Terry what his name was and he
did not know but I believe you've told
the jury last week that he did remember
his name
it was he had to really think hard about
it took like four or five seconds for
him to to remember his name
but that's not what you wrote here you
wrote here Terry did not know his name
when I first asked him he didn't know
his name he had to really think about it
I asked Terry what his name was and he
did not know
yeah he when I asked him he he didn't
didn't know his name and then he he just
took some time to kind of just think
about it and then he you know after
about four or five seconds he just said
to Terry
Okay so
what you wrote here is not what you told
the jury last week is that fair to say
um
could you please repeat that just he
here in your note you do not say that he
did later remember his name you just say
he didn't remember it all and as I
understand it that was different than
what you told the jury last three week
is that correct yes when I when I when I
was when I basically was was talking
about about this I didn't go into much
detail you know on on this
I was just making a point that he was
having a hard time knowing what his name
was
okay so let's go to this last
page page well I guess there's a kind of
blank page at the end but page eight the
last page with your comments on it
do you see up there at the top
another one of your comments
okay
this is hard to see
what is that Focus I'm learning old
technology I appreciate this thank you
okay so
um
in this comment that you wrote correct
this this top comment is yours Mr Ramon
yes it is okay and in this comment you
wrote Gwyneth took out Terry last week
last Saturday her son broke his arms
looking at Park City how did you know
that
there's a lady I know that works at
health and I mean works at Snowbird and
Deer Valley she works up with a montage
or Deer Valley and and she told me
okay
and then Gwyneth was staying at the
Montage how did you know that that's
what she told me
and why were you talking to her about
Gwyneth
uh she just she knew what happened and
then she told me that what happened
sorry that's not clear to me so she knew
what happened she she knew that uh that
Gwyneth took out took out Terry and so
then when I saw her she told me what
happened I didn't ask her about it she
just told me when that that's what
happened but she wasn't there at the
Collision right
no she just worked up up at the hotel so
how would she have any knowledge of it
I have no idea
she took her plane out of millionaire
airport how did you know about Miss
Gwyneth or Miss Paltrow's travels one of
my best friends he works at a
millionaire and that's where a lot of
the the private jets the charter Jets
that's where they fly into that that
part of the airport
it sounds to me like you were talking to
a lot of people about Gwyneth Paltrow
during this time is that correct know my
best my best friend he knew what
happened and he's the one who told me
so you didn't tell these people what
happened even though you were the one at
the Collision site yeah I told my friend
what happened
okay
so you were telling people about this
this accident yes I've told people and
then they were telling you things they
knew about Miss Paltrow that at least
they claimed to know about Miss Paltrow
yeah
but they could be mistaken is that
correct yes
so if Miss Paltrow's son didn't in fact
break his arm while skiing you wouldn't
dispute that he wouldn't have any way to
dispute that correct I have no idea
what I was told
um let me go back I just have I think
one more question for you
so if you were to look at
page let's go to page seven
those comments that I believe you've
connected to Terry Sanderson
those ones in the middle of the page you
can read them to yourself but my
question is given that you've described
him as being knocked out cold in other
comments here
um
I I wanted to ask you whether you found
Terry to be articulate in his posts and
comments on this page
following his injury
sustained as to vagueness if you could
point out something okay
so
um
maybe it's better to go
these are kind of difficult because they
don't have
dates on each comment correct they just
show
for example
this one at the bottom you see on very
Terry or very tease comment it says 2584
days ago correct
yes let's see that okay and James
okay yeah I don't know that so I'm
asking Mr Ramon do you know when these
comments were made is this on the day
of the accident when he says you are
organized a perfect day
I don't see where it says you organized
I don't see it worse worse is to say
that that you organized a perfect day uh
it's the on page six the the third
comment down
well he's looking at that with Council
approach please
so Mr Ramon this comment I'm pointing to
you
um pointing you to on page six says it's
under very T yes Kurt you organized a
perfect day
uh for skiing thank you
that's true Scott I still have my wheels
it was nice to get to know you a bit
today do you know whether that was
written on the day of the accident
not sure who was or not would it
surprise you that Mr Sanderson was
writing articulate notes like this after
being knocked out and unconscious for
two minutes
uh doesn't send an articulates me but
okay that's all I have thanks
Mr Bueller
Craig can you look at page six again
in the middle under very t
uh do you see that where it says yes
Kurt you organize a perfect day
yes I do
and then um look at the number of days
it is
it 2584 yes it is and then your comment
below that
says 2583 days ago
yes so those comments were made on
different days
yes
okay
thank you
any follow-up Mr Egan okay you may step
down Mr Ramon hey thank you you still
remain subject to the orders of the
Court until the case is over or you're
released so thank you thank you
leave it right there
plan if you may call your next Witness
thank you for coming
it's called
Mr Terry Sanderson
hi please face right here okay do you
swear that that the testimony you were
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God
thank you have a seat good morning sir
[Music]
I want you to get comfortable and speak
into the mic okay okay all right okay
could you state and spell your name for
the record please
yes
my name is Terry
t-e-r-r-y Howard h-o-w-a-r-d Sanderson
s-a-n-d-e-r-s-o-n thank you now Terry
this is the fifth day of trial we
started last Tuesday
um
you haven't you weren't here much last
week were you not at all in the court in
the courtroom were you in the courthouse
yes definitely
sure
thank you
Terry did you want to be here the last
four days last week inside the courtroom
I love spending time with my daughters
you have to hear what they had to say
but in this case
I
didn't want to be here because I wanted
them to speak totally freely and without
the discomfort and being in my presence
if they had something to say is that why
you weren't here absolutely yes
we're going to cut to the chase on a lot
of things because I made counsel a
promise that I would have you in less
than an hour and so we're I'm going to
be true to my word here it's 10 o'clock
I will have we'll be done before 11.
okay
I want to talk about skiing
tell the jury about your ski experience
what type of skier were you
at that time or do you want some
background I we don't need a whole lot
of background okay back in
I was Advanced intermediate there was
places I would go except
um serious bumps
um
narrow narrow little gulches and um
uh didn't do any any big jumps so other
than that I would go just about anywhere
okay how often would you ski two to
three times per week
for how many years
well I started 37 years ago it was a
winter sport for my family we lived at
high elevation
and in all of your years other than the
ski collision with Miss Paltrow have you
ever been in another ski accident
never
have you ever skied with the ski Patrol
matter of fact I had the Good Fortune I
learned to ski
from a family that owned a ski resort
they were
they were relation and they would come
out to Snowbird and
they were I think
it was a whole family-run operation with
eight children and so they they were ski
patrollers and they were instructors and
I had the very best of company every
winter for a week when the kids were out
of school
and then I had the Good Fortune of
having a Lions Club friend Scott who's
still a dear friend that lives up in
Spokane and he was a ski patroller for
turkey and he said Terry come up with me
you know on this weekend and and I said
I'll slow you down he said you know what
just follow me and do what I do and
that's what I did
and I had the Good Fortune of spending a
lot of time with Scott and seeing and
observing what ski patrols do and how
they calm people down and reassure them
they're going to be okay so I really
appreciated that and
experience so it sounds like you've
skied at Snowbird skeeted turkey
had you ever skied at Deer Valley
on the day of the Collision no
that was your first time ever yes it was
okay
let's talk about that day
um
a couple of preliminary things I asked
Miss Paltrow on Friday how tall she was
how tall are you
I think I'm now five five
and what was your weight at the time of
the Collision well in the VA you don't
take anything off you whatever you walk
in with your coach heavy coast and
wintertime boots
how much did you weigh about fully
dressed I was undressed probably 63 62
pounds 163 162. okay all right
so
we've the jury's heard about meetup
groups
what is a Meetup Group
a meet-up group was just a lifesaver for
me being new to this area
um hard to accumulate friends and so
when a fellow that I was on a hike with
a new fellow said have you heard of
Meetup and I hadn't so he says look it
up and sign up and I did and it was a
wonderful organization of groups of
people where you had a shared interest
whether it was dancing or concerts or
skiing
and so I signed up and joined some
groups and it was really a life changer
okay so my understanding is the day of
this ski Collision you were with kind of
a group of people in the Meetup group is
that fair that's right all right
did the group have a plan or were you
the organizer of that Meetup group that
day no I was not I'd asked Kurt to take
that over because I planned on being
gone that day and Kirk organized that
okay
okay sounds like obviously you weren't
gone that day you ended up being able to
make it
I came back a little early from from
wherever I was and and just said oh I'm
gonna go ski today and I happened to see
on the list that day also was a lady
that I had met when I first moved here
and she happened to be a ski instructor
at Canyons and but she had been at Deer
Valley as well and so I called and said
Debbie I got I'm going to go I'll pick
you up picture up at Kimball Junction on
the way and went there with her and
dropped her off the skies
we met the group and I asked her if it'd
be okay if she let our group out because
she's very familiar with Deer Valley
so she said yes and gave us the rules of
the road would you like to hear that so
the Meetup Group you guys kind of ski
all together ish well and this skiing
meetup group is unusual it's like
herding cats you've got those that just
want to go and and they kind of know who
one another is and so they they go ahead
and and group up and and sometimes I
wind up skiing with the beginners and
getting them started making them
comfortable and uh so they don't stay
together well we meet usually we'll say
let's meet at Alps at 1 30 and so that's
what we do okay so you mentioned we set
forth the rules of Road for that day
pulls up the road that day well the only
rules of the road we are pretty familiar
with the rules of the roads so we don't
go over that at the time but Debbie just
said we're going to start Dan Band down
bandana because that's how we'll get to
the blacks are really good skiing so our
group knew that's where we're headed
and she said whatever you do on bandana
do not go down the middle of the Run
yeah packed and crowded with people she
said go down the edges
it'll be clear
and so when I came over the edge of the
Hill
there were heads bobbing in the middle
it was just compacted with little heads
and big tall heads and and I just
diagonaled I went straight over to the
right edge of that run
and is that where you stayed prior to
the Collision
I did I stayed there the whole time
because
it was wide open so you were over to the
right side to avoid the people did it
have anything to do with your vision
there's been a lot of discussion about
your your right eye problem and we'll
talk about that in a few minutes but
skiing on the right side of the the uh
the Run did that have anything to do
with your right eye
yeah maybe that's one of the things yes
okay
we'll talk about your vision in just a
couple minutes but I want to focus on
the Collision right now
Craig Ramon he just testified
oh yes you saw him he he also testified
last week how well did you know Craig at
the time
um back February February 2016.
um he was one of maybe an average of 15
people 10 or 15 people would come so I
shared his company during those times
and I knew him only as being
an amazing skier strong strong skier and
and knew that and I appreciated the fact
he tended to like to follow the group
and be behind as the protector because
he brought a lady that was a person I
knew that was his neighbor so he would
bring her up and ski behind her as a
protector so guy good guy
did you guys hang out a lot before this
college
um of course at lunch we spent time
together and there may be a couple of
other occasions where we met with him
but usually there was somebody else
there
um along with us okay so not exclu I
don't remember being exclusive with him
all right
so Terry
take the jury through
what happened in this ski Collision take
it from say getting off of the lift
yes happy to
happen
um
it was really a very nice day for skiing
and I was really looking forward to it
and of course you really has amazing
groomed runs found that out right away
and um so
um
I'm starting from the want to get off
when you got off of the ski lift gotcha
so I was on a chair with probably four
people I think Joanne Debbie Craig and
there could have been another person
besides myself
and we had already met and discussed
going down the right side of that run or
going down the sides
and so I came over the top of the hill
and saw that and headed for the right
side and I'll pick it up there
and everyone just kind of dispersed some
more to the right and more to the left
and I remember looking and seeing no one
and they
generally beginner runs people are
afraid of the off-peast of the off
groomers and so they stay away from that
area where the pile of snow is piled up
and a piece can be a rough ride if you
have to divert and run out in there
some skiers can't make it through
they're easy it's a lot of bumps
so I start I went right down the run and
started just making nice soft turns and
staying within that boundary it could
have been as much as five yards wide but
it might have been more like
five or six feet
I don't can't imagine I can't remember
lots of room
and so I'm just risking easy and paying
attention and all of a sudden in front
of me is
two big signs I've never seen that big
of slow down signs it seemed like they
were four by eight like a four by eight
sheet of plywood size high with great
big letters slow down
I went whoa and I'm looking around and
the crowd's about the same as me and
speed wise
I did and I backed off whatever I was
doing and then another big sign like 10
feet away the same eight by four by
eight sheet up there big letters well
they're serious must be lots of emerging
Trails down here
so
um I just backed off and again
the skiers were on my left we're all
about the same speed
and um
I could see down
where the edge of the Run went it curved
around a tree line came out a little bit
and a little run came turned curled
around and I could see about half of the
I don't know if some Montage or the
Empire could about half of that
beautiful building and
and
um it was wide open there was nothing
nothing in front of me and so
um I came around that corner and it was
takes my breath away to think this is
hard because I don't like going through
this scene
I
I just remember everything was great and
then I heard something I've never heard
of the ski resort and that was a blood
curdling scream
just I can't do it
and then
boom
and
it was like somebody was out of control
and gonna hit a tree and was gonna die
and
that's what I had until I was hit
that's what's going on in your mind when
you hear that scream
that's instantaneous oh my gosh
somebody's out of control and they're
really seriously out of control not time
for hawkish I didn't go think about that
but most people could avoid that I think
the good skiers okay
and I'm fine
so you he
he's
overruled
so you hear this scream yes
what happens next
you know I got hit in my back so hard
and I I'm right at my shoulder blades
and it felt like and was perfectly
centered and the fish and the poles were
right there at the bottom of my shoulder
blades
serious serious smack never been hit
that hard and I'm flying I'm absolutely
flying now you're not airborne
well it all I saw was a whole lot of
snow and
I didn't see the sky
but I was flying in that sense I had no
control
and I remember
this thinking okay you really gotta hang
on and then I thought about the crowd on
the left and I thought I don't know
who's wanted over there and I do not
want to get them mixed up in here and
I've heard you know um
that maybe that's not decided about how
my ribs really got hurt I absolutely
lurched
to what little I could offer my skis a
little bit more to the right to keep to
make sure nobody over here got involved
on my left side
and then it was like the grounds coming
up
nobody in front of me just me going to
the ground and you're falling far
further than 90 degrees like you fall on
the floor
you you got that extra and so it's quite
a waste to hit the ground
and I just said okay you've got to
protect your face you know in your head
and
that's the last thing I remember it
didn't happen I did glance over and saw
just just out of the corner of my eye
could see not glance over but I could
see somebody going by and I'm going okay
they're safe
last thing I remember everything's black
did the person who struck you land on
top of you
I wouldn't know that I absolutely would
not know that I was just surprised I had
no upper body strength enough to be able
to catch myself I had no idea
remember hitting your head on the ground
no that part no
no it's all gone I just remember it my
arms collapsing and that's the last
thing I remember what's the next thing
you remember
I'm getting an adrenaline rush here I
guess living this again
just being here and present too and let
me just stop you really quick you said
you're getting an adrenaline rush is
this something that you enjoy
Adrenaline Rush not this kind not now
okay all right so what's the first thing
that you remember
or the next thing that you remember
after Europe yes on the ground
um the first remembers everything is
still black
like I'm unconscious
and
but it's like my subconscious is going
into protection mode like
you better pay attention here and listen
to what's being said to you and
all I could recognize was that someone
was really angry at me
and it was a man and it didn't come out
clear in the beginning
couldn't really hear what he was saying
but I just knew he was mad and he was
right right above me right close to me
and
I'm feeling a little afraid
and I tried to move and I could not move
a limb I couldn't move my head
I couldn't move my body nothing was
responding just this message I was
getting
and the next thing
it became became a little more clear and
I heard him say Do You Realize
realize that you weren't skiing under
the rules you hit somebody you hurt
somebody and it just insistent that I
was the bad guy and that's why I said
this has got to be a husband or
boyfriend it's
really mad at me and I sound like a big
did you know who he was I had no idea no
idea it was just a very angry person
trying to
bully me into believing something that I
didn't think Could Happen was I heard a
woman's voice right
again couldn't move and about the third
time he went through that and it's
getting louder and
it's I could start to understand what he
was saying and he was really insistent
that I
was doing something wrong
and hit somebody
and I remember in desperation because I
couldn't move anything
try to I couldn't fight I couldn't
flight who's who's going to try and I
tried moving something and I could move
my skis a little bit I could just feel
just blowing my knee I could just slide
my skis a little bit so and and
that's an important point my skis are
still on they're still on and
I'm
I'm thinking I gotta placate this guy
he's really mad if he decided he wanted
to jump on me
right now I could finish me off I was so
I remember I remember saying
I'm sorry
okay now you're you're with your
Whispering I know I am because that's
what I heard nothing was coming out my
lips were moving my tongue was moving
there was nothing coming out of my mouth
and my heart rate went up again
it looked like what you were mouthing
was I'm sorry I'm sorry and and I was
just going I can't believe it I thought
I'd try again
nothing was coming out and and to me I
heard nothing
when you kind of mumbled whispered
whatever you want to call it I'm sorry
was that you apologizing for causing the
accident no absolutely not I was trying
to placate this man in the only
defensive manner that I could okay
talked about the man who
talked about and admitted that she was
kind of cussing you out as well do you
remember any conversation that you had
or anything that she said to you
absolutely not there was one voice that
my brain was focused on
thank God I guess and and that was
self-protection I guess I only heard a
male voice a mad angry male voice I
heard nothing maybe that happened before
I came to that point in Consciousness
were you still on the ground at this
time
still on the ground absolutely face down
how did you end up getting up
well that's a story too but
um basically
I heard Craig saying Terry are you
okay now this is Craig Ramon well at
that point I didn't identify as voice I
you know I just things were a little
strange at and
and I heard Terry are you okay
and um in about the third time it hit me
somebody's wants to is here to help me
and at that point except an angry man
was there
and I
I said
oh my gosh and I went through
and I I looked up and I could see Craig
standing there above me eight or ten
feet and on his immediate left
my right was a man in an all green
outfit and with a helmet on and ski
goggles and
you know look good and um and I thought
oh he's here to help me right he looks
like he's from Deer Valley and so
um
I I was going through
the things answering his question about
that with my thoughts you know back to
my what my injuries are Craig is saying
are you okay and I said oh my my ribs
are so sore there's just this really
deep throbbing purple pain here and and
then I said
um my vision is swimming with Sparks and
they were unusual Sparks I'm going is
that my retina is that my eyes and it
wasn't a rally attachment or rent a hole
or anything and I'm going that's my
brain I'm thinking those Sparks
on my brain and all this time you're
still on the ground I'm still I'm
actually yeah the next point is that
after I tell him about my ears going
under my ears are buzzing oh and my said
my brain is like it's on novocaine and
and then I realized oh I'm not she oh I
you know what I missed a spot and that's
where I looked up and couldn't see them
and got frightened about that and I
realized going oh my what's going on and
then I went like this I go
oh I was happy I could see so I missed
that part that happened before I started
telling what all is wrong with me
answering his question and then Craig
said to me
is I remember of course I'm
my brains are a little bit
stretched out of this place and
and I I re I remember him saying do you
know who you are
and what I thought I said was
oh my gosh I can feel this pathway in my
brain it's going around and trying to
figure out who I am and yes I know I'm
Terry
and
then he said do you know where you are
and I said I know I'm skiing but I don't
know where I am and that's when the man
in green
took off
he was I was kind of noticing that he
really wasn't interested in what I had
to say he wasn't asking questions he was
standing there rather stoically head not
moving God's on
just resting on his poles and his skis
and
was so sort of disinterested but when he
skied off my heart sank because I really
thought he was the one person that was
there to help me
and and I'm laying on the ground with my
head downhill and I couldn't see where
he went
so I was really
Terry how did you get up
the question is how I got up and that
might have been the question in the
beginning but that's right how did you
get up
you know I realized that I was getting
cold
and snow was packed in around me I'm
starting to get a little shivery Maybe
from
a little shockish maybe and
and I started I got to go I got to get
my skis downhill and I started sliding
my skis around and my legs around I
think Craig must have been Shell Shocked
about this guy leaving too I don't know
but what he thought but
I remember getting my skis around and
it's so painful every time you have to
contract your Terry thank you how did
you get up
yeah that is one of my habits
after I got halfway around
a man showed up in front of me and I
thought he came from the right
and I don't remember if he shed one word
to me he just reached down and grabbed
me and jerked me on
on my feet which I was not ready to be
up on my feet my head's swimming I'm in
pain I'm worried about falling down
again and breaking a rib puncturing
along
he gets me up and I'm on the edge of the
run so it's bumpy it's
hard to get my skis under me and I'm
stomping down the snow and trying to get
him in the spot got my
got my poles wedged in and I think I've
got it under stability and
he's gone
and this time
I could see him I could watch him go all
the way down the hill
and I'm I'm standing up with am I
feeling safe no people are going by
you know
and I'm thinking man I do not want to
get hit again
my understanding is that you and Craig
tried to ski down a little ways but then
didn't quite make it too far is that
accurate yeah he said you think he can
ski and I'm thinking if I the option is
getting left up here I will try anything
I got to get off here
so yes he said follow me and I did
and I don't know how I skiing I don't
think I was edging I think I was
probably snow plowing and he finally
turned around and said Terry
Terry stop you've forgotten how to ski
and of course it was just we were
trapped and he said I gotta find help
right here
eventually create God help yes
yeah Aisha I gotta find help and so he
disappeared and I just put my head down
and
prayed that
I wouldn't get smacked into again I felt
pretty vulnerable
and he disappeared what happened when
help arrived
you know
um Whitney showed up and I'm so grateful
to see someone
and now is that Whitney Smith yes that's
your name and the jury has seen pictures
and we're gonna put another picture up
in just a couple minutes is she the one
in a red jacket
there's a picture of in this case do you
know yes as a matter of yes that's her
all right so did she take you down on
the toboggan or how did you get down she
did
um she said are you are you okay kind of
thing and I don't know it's not so good
I don't remember the conversation it was
literally easy stuff and
so um
got in and I remember Whitney saying to
me now
you got to remember these things because
I'm going to ask again later
and she told me that she was from
Michigan with five years before and it
started on the ski patrol here five
years before she loved her job
her name was Whitney and that she had a
horse named Titan that she wore in the
years off so she told me to remember
those things I'm going this is a brain
test she's wanting
to check if my brain's okay
and from that point on
I quit worrying about myself I
went about my injuries it was just like
I'm going to remember this I do not want
to have any brain injuries
and I locked onto that and and nothing
else and later on she did ask me and I
could repeat it back to her exactly as
she told me
and I wish she won the women's downhill
in the ski patrol of women's competition
sounds like you still remember it just I
was so determined to hang on to that
fact those facts yes
all right
once you got down
what type of medical attention did you
receive
still at the ski resort yeah oh Whitney
is not a paramedic she's not an EMT
um I I didn't really expect her to have
advanced knowledge about neurological
testing and pupil testing and cranial
nerve testing she did
she did a great job of doing exactly
what she's supposed to do just to be at
that triage level to decide what kind of
care I needed okay so what what type of
care did you get
you get medical treatment did you get
when you got down to the bottom
did you get checked out at the InstaCare
or anybody after after yes we left there
yes
um I asked Debbie I said where can I go
and get checked and see what they say
and she said well let's stop at the
InstaCare I know it's on the way
so I'd never been there before but
that's where we stopped and went in
there okay
so you got checked out
when did you learn that it was Gwyneth
Paltrow that you were in the collision
with
it was it was brought up I think that
the people that came in uh to the room
to check on me that were part of my
group would check in and check out once
and and
um which is what I tell them go ski and
go enjoy yourself and um
and so um it came up and it probably was
Craig who said I heard him say it was
Gwen and Paul Joe
and to me it's like
I'm not into celebrity worship so
I
didn't care at that point did you think
it was cool
to collide with a celebrity absolutely
not
that is not who I am no
do you ever write that
ever tell anybody that I don't think it
came out in those words but I don't
remember but
I
I think I was trying to communicate to
my kids and the reason was because I got
calls from friends that knew my kids at
heard I got
crushed on at the ski resort and so I
I
thought I gotta I gotta let my kids know
I'm okay that was my main point I don't
want him to worry about me I'm okay and
so I just I started it out and may said
I'm famous or something okay we're going
to pull that out could you pull
yes defense exhibit 111.
we're going to call it the I'm famous
email
[Music]
sometimes old technology like the ammo
works better than the new technology
doesn't it
you're not going to plug it in oh
foreign
you could come down if you need to or
does it show on your screen there
um yeah but
I'm not the
being an eye doctor I'm not wearing
fashion because I broke the pair of
glasses I bought and couldn't find the
old pair so now I'm okay
all right so I want to go through this
um defense exhibit 111.
do you see
first of all
there are two posts the first looks like
on the bottom
is the first
at uh
eight o'clock P.M and then the response
was at 9 32 PM do you see that I do all
right
the message reads and I'm just just
telling me if I read it right from you
to Jenny Polly and Shay those are your
three daughters yes there okay and the
subject said I'm famous
do you see that I do why did you write
I'm famous
you know again my head was scrambled all
I was trying to do is desperately
communicate with my kids before they
heard from somebody else I got crushed
so
um I didn't pick my words well
not at all how I felt and I really was
trying to add a little levity to a
serious situation and it backfired
little did I know that this is where to
be
um so you're right I'm famous and then
here's what happened from my friend and
eyewitness and then there's the link
the link the link We Now know what the
link shows
sorry I thought you were going to the
GoPro I'll withdraw my comment
I'm just talking about the link yes
so we now know what the link is yes
correct the link is
it's a really bad picture
yeah
you'll get a clear picture it's the
picture of Whitney Smith
oh it's right there fantastic
okay it's that
and then that leads to later comments
back and forth between you and Craig yes
in that under that picture can you read
what it says
um
Whitney kept me entertained while
probing you want to speak in the mic oh
yes
um Whitney kept me entertained while
probing me with questions to evaluate my
senses a dedicated outdoor person and
horse lover from Michigan she also took
me down in the toboggan by herself and
won the DV women's downhill
race contest
are those the first of all did you write
that under her picture you know I don't
know what time it was added Carlene was
hurrying back from St George and
depending I don't know
um she helped me a lot
um verbalize things because things
weren't making sense at all and all
right communication and she may have
helped and participated in that
those details are those the details that
Whitney wanted you to memorize as you
were taking down the toboggan
to the emails
all right so you send that out to your
three daughters I did yes and Shea who
testified last week she responded to you
with the top post correct yes all right
can you read what it says actually let's
put the subject read what the subject
says
it says I'm famous at what cost question
mark
do you know why she wrote that
well that
do you know I think
she may have called me
did she um right after this and um and
so speculation you're right sustained
to remember
um
I'm pretty certain that she checked in
on me and made a phone call
and um what what did do you remember
what you told her during the phone call
yeah I had a chance to talk about my
symptoms exactly I think and and that I
I said
should you know as many people that were
on that slope that day maybe a couple
hundred within that vicinity
there has to be a GoPro picture or video
if it's a helmet mount
they're going to look over just like
Craig did right and they're going to go
catch it they hear a holler they're
going to catch it I'm going I just know
there's one out there we've got to find
that that is the evidence we need
and so
Terry she misinterpreted did you have a
GoPro absolutely I do have one yes but I
did not have it on that day do you know
of anybody in your ski group that had a
GoPro
have you ever seen a GoPro video of this
app absolutely not no I would have loved
to have it it was what we needed
all right
okay
let's talk about this to your
understanding did you sustain in this
Collision
right now what your understanding as to
what happened to Terry in this collision
at this point I know that I had at least
at least four broken ribs
um I sustained a concussion and
um
that's the
two main factors I think and then
later on had some right leg and still do
right leg and anomalies movement it just
has its own
idea and thinking where it needs to be
opposed to what I'm thinking
let's talk about how
your ribs how your brain injury how that
has affected you okay
have things in your life changed
I'm like living another life now
let's focus on we'll kind of goes step
by step different different things
physical wise
how how have you changed physically
since the accident
well
I can't ski anymore I was told
that if I did and had another crash
that I could wind up full time
full-time in a nursing home
the odds of that's very high
so no more skiing well and I I tried
I tried not to go back and
and I did ski a few more times by myself
just to see if I still could I had this
ungodly looking fluorescent red outfit I
bought a mips helmet to protect my brain
better and I thought I can do this I
really this is my love and joy I meet
friends I make friends I stay with them
the whole year they're it's a year-round
activity and it's a life
lifelong activity
and so I I tried and I felt like I was
skiing through land lines just
ridiculous looked ridiculous all bright
fluorescent red wasn't thinking very
well and then
and then I'd have to stop every 30 yards
and look back behind me to make sure no
one was right behind me
saw reaction
and um gradually gave it up just three
four times I think it was done okay
we go into more Act
[Music]
Ive your physical being
how are you
um
I'm I'm a much more careful person
I don't take any risks and
more brain damage and
I'm not sure I understand your question
exactly have you had any kinds of
balance issues or headaches
um of course initially
that was just I my life was living in an
orange chair
sitting there
initially and sleep for 12 hours and
then
sit for half an hour until Carlene I got
a
go back to bed to be fair it's not like
that anymore
no it's not no
I
I had no anymore no it's not
let's talk about mentally how
how have
you seen yourself change mentally what
are some things that you've noticed or
difficulties that you've had mentally
many things I don't have the words
or the intelligence you're training to
explain you have lots of words I do
I admit it's just this has been a
bizarre part of this process as I never
feel like I've explained enough
there's I it's like big gaps I go I
gotta start from the beginning and
everyone May recognize that by going
through and building a case and they
don't know what I'm talking about until
I get to the subject so it's everything
is backwards I'm building from the
little things and and then saying oh I'm
talking about apples they're going I had
no idea
it's communication just feels like I I
can't connect
and and so I keep trying desperately
trying
and and
um
yeah personality changes is not
something I I just know it's different
things are weird
you ever get lost
oh my gosh that was among the first
signs when I tried to get out and work
on the Green Team and um wait what's the
green
tea what I'm talking about I volunteer
for lots of groups um couple hundred
years hours a year at least I would
think and green team is one of those is
significant a large group of heavy heavy
lifters who pick up
um
plastic and aluminum recycle after
concerts and USANA was the main one even
though we've done Liberty Park and it's
a group of maybe 15 people and we stay
up until one o'clock in the morning
picking that up up there and recycled
the last year I worked in 2015 23 tons
and it's not just walking 16 000 steps
on what I saw and it's bending and
scooping and lifting and picking up and
dragging a bag and it's hard work but
really really binding with a lot of
people and doing that so that's what
that is so I tried going up there
and I and
usually I carpool
and that day I didn't
usually the driver and so I parked and
went and did our thing and it's maybe 12
31 o'clock and went back to the car and
headed home
I'm going the wrong direction I'm going
what's going on I've done this dozens of
times I was
washed now just to clarify this is since
the the ski crash right oh yes okay
in my instincts are always knowing where
North End has really been good having
grown up in the mountains it just was
instinctual
at night
I had no instincts anymore anyway and so
I headed just instinctually where I
thought supposed to be and wound up
north or south or somewhere else and
that happened a second time
had that ever happened to you before
this ski Collision I've never been so
reliable relying needing
maps and so
um
I I'm pretty sure I've lost visual
memory because it doesn't knowing those
turns in the house is where you turn the
streets should turn at
that feels like and I know a little bit
about that that feels like a deficit I
have that that doesn't I don't retain
that anymore I can be there a dozen
times and I still have to use maps to
make sure I get there really odd
what about emotional Terry how are your
relationships with your family and
friends since the ski accident
you know my interaction with my family
has been more difficult
and I I think I
of course I'm desperately to be close to
my family and my girls
but something's wrong in my Essence and
what I what I bring to the table with
them and communication is not as smooth
and and
it's it's been more difficult no
question and they've they've told me
they've noticed some changes yeah now I
didn't know you before Jerry didn't know
you before
what kind of relationships did you have
with your girls before this crash
my goals are always angels
I'm their protector
things happen to them I'm testifying
that
I heard about it
about it it hurts to see them in their
places or protector
I rode home with them and shopping so I
get caught up in that
do you love your girls
oh my gosh
there's been some discussion about your
relationship with Jenny and that it's
not always optimal
from your perspective what is your
relationship like with Jenny and how has
it been even before this accident
yeah Jenny Jenny and I
I probably don't communicate as well as
I do with my other two daughters not
probably definitely we don't
have a hard time
um in that process and I will not give
up my
try to push to
keep that those lines open but there's
been times when there's been long
breaches in our conversation
and um
yeah I
I feel like her protector more than
anybody does so it's hard been harder
for me to transition from being a parent
to being
an adult
an equal adult I just feel like I need
to intervene more on her behalf
and help her
just been hard
let's talk about Carlene we heard her
testify last week she's a catch why'd
you let her go
in my choice I would have but I had it
after eight months I had to tell her to
leave
I said I'm not asking I'm telling you
you got to leave
and
I'm
why'd you tell her to leave
I knew she didn't buy into this she
didn't buy in to me not being the same
person and coming
into a relationship and
and I said I'm not sure I'm going to get
to back to normal again
and
I don't want you to feel like you're
that I'm a
crippled vet you're gonna stick it out
with me because I know you would half a
brain or whatever I know you would but
don't do it
you need your life you run right now and
it was a sad time for both of us I know
and she's in a great relationship with
Bill now and that was the purpose and I
think better than what I would have
brought honestly
it's hard to admit that but it's true
sure okay we'll take a short recess
why don't you stand now and then you're
welcome to step down during the break
hmm
Council would you approach the bench
please
the men's and women's soccer teams are
finally being paid equally
but why stop at soccer let's achieve pay
equity for everyone lead the way in Fair
pay with Jose will you rise to the
challenge
earn up to 180 in alley points when you
get treated with Juvederm filler in
botox cosmetic at the same visit
the Juvederm collection of fillers is
specifically designed to add volume to
different areas of the face botox
cosmetic can temporarily improve the
look of moderate to severe forehead
that's good I agree noises less than
what I'd like to do and what I've done
in Prior trials is actually
moved to publish the deposition and then
bring up
on this
the highlighted sentence and answer
because it's really slowed things down
and I
uh from my deposition with Mr Sanderson
I I suspect there's going to be that
kind of slowness too and I'd rather just
bring it up
we'd rather
do it the normal way which is uh
they read the deposition but they don't
show it
I think I'll permit it on because this
is a party
and under rule 32 it can be used for any
purpose I thought he meant for the other
businesses and as long as you know the
the section that you're using for
impeachment Mr Owens is the only section
that's appearing up there
we'll do it all right yes we're okay
with that I thought he was talking about
some of the other witnesses that were
preparing you see last night we we
thought we'd find out if Kerry Oaks was
going to be offered we shoot
pardon we could bring in the jury okay
let's call him in
yes yes you did
copies of the depositions there were
actually it was three sittings and can
we go put them up there one two three
and give you a copy yes do you mind yes
Peter
these are for the court yes
if you're putting it up on the screen I
mean for the witness they may not need
to actually go into this
that may save you some time
but but put them there just in case the
witness needs them
Miss Van Norman thank you
oh it wasn't you who broke it
I've got one side hiring the other
house that's
that's the lean inside but everything
else functions well on it
I'll tell you what just leave it we'll
we'll work around it okay all right so
let's get back to some of the things
that you've noticed we've heard from
others but I want to hear from you yes
um
have you had any type of anger issues
since
the Collision
that you've noticed there's no question
I have a much wider range of
yeah temperament than I had before much
wider
what about your social life do you
before before the ski accident what kind
of things did you do
you know I I look back in the last
couple of years in fact I did that and I
just realized I was in the groove of my
life at that stage
I had a lady in my life that I dearly
loved
and
um we just did everything together
and spent I believe it was two years
together and had cleaned up our lives
and physically great shape both of us
like to hike and walk and travel and
really we're enjoying our lives and we
spent some time in St George where she's
located and I spent some time here just
wonderful we cleaned up the businesses
of homes and combining homes and parents
homes and and we had
she as I hope everybody noticed she is
an amazing woman and so a great deal of
connection with her
and so since
the car or the car
accident
do fun things and have that
zest for life
I've been self-imposed
um
90 percent
staying in the house a recluse
self-imposed recluse just not feeling as
fun
not feeling as engaged in other things
not just don't have that
same spark I had
and don't feel the same about when I go
to places
um you still travel though
you know I have trapped because what
let's put it let's talk about travel for
a minute before the ski Collision
did you do a lot of travel a lot of
travel it happened to be something that
Carlene liked to do and so we we've
traveled a lot went on the only cruise
that I was ever on before the crash and
yes we had and we had War plans did you
ever travel alone
the ski Collision
have you still traveled
I have traveled and
as part of the problem just easily
confused about things
so I usually request having somebody
else along also because of this funny
apparent foot thing you want to go its
own way
I don't feel as safe
and then also
yeah things would happen like I put the
wrong name and get their name spelled
wrong and it's important flight tickets
and and the birth date which
so it was it was difficult and I really
wanted someone to go with me I didn't
feel a secure traveling alone have you
traveled alone since the ski accident
I have not I had one time when a friend
one friend there's actually two but I
had one friend when we planned a trip to
Europe
a physician's assistant and
my yoga instructor and she decided right
before the trip Terry
I don't like you anymore I don't know
what's different you're a different
person I don't like you anymore
how'd that make you feel
it was like
oh my gosh my gosh I'd known her as long
and one other one as well as long as
I've lived here almost five years I'm
guessing at that time
and
personality like that's something it
develops from the time of your child how
what do you do about a personality issue
changed and
aggressive and you know what that lady
will not answer her phone or texts
and I have well we're not going to say
her name on on
um
she's a lovely lady yes she is have your
other friendships been affected as well
another lady that I knew for quite some
time a sweetheart also of a woman
um we just got off kelter a little bit
well after Carlene
after I told Carlene she had to run it
was a few weeks later I couldn't realize
how lonely I was yes I should have taken
more time to absorb that but I was so
lonely because we were together all the
time
so I reached out to her and we spent a
couple of things activities together and
I couldn't believe the words that came
out of her mouth she said
Terry it is it is hearsay so we can't
you can't testify as to what she said
she said but how did it make you feel
well
it made me feel like what's wrong with
me and
how do I fix my personality how do I fix
it I'm a different person
it's a pretty complex issue
and a loose self-confidence
the person I am I'm going what happened
what happened Terry are you trying to
improve yourself
I've been in denial
I've been in denial about my issue I
refuse to believe I have brain issues
I've just done everything I can I knew I
had a critical window to restore stuff
and I did everything I was told and
everything I could find out about trying
to get
those
neurons
reconfigured in a good way
and I haven't found this helped so I'm
still in denial I keep thinking there's
got to be something are you trying to
improve yourself yes I don't want to
have reaches I'm trying to prove I don't
have it everything I do I'm trying to
prove I don't have that wrong with me
it's been a lot of discussion discuss
about how Terry
put up
defense exhibit 23 please
and I'm actually going to move forward
the admission of the entire defense
exhibit 23 I'm assuming there's no
objection
does any of this need to be redacted so
uh let me just state that my
understanding was that miss van Orman
was going to be done at 11. I almost
changed right now she's moving for a
defense exhibit 23 any objection
okay so it was received
to the redaction concern I do believe
at least some parts of it maybe need
that but it looks like we're not showing
those
are you showing his address for instance
um but well
at the bottom of that
do you have that exhibit in front of you
I think I do yes
I yes I think I do
all right there's the address there yep
thank you
do you see where it says Chief complaint
down at the bottom
yes I do yes it says regular visit yes
was this a regular visit that you were
attending with um
with with your provider
um
it could be I I
don't know I usually saw her once a year
once every six months so if that's what
it says I believe that's okay and just
for reference Terry I know you weren't
here but this is the I'm getting old
exhibit
that I'm getting old visit because you
go to the next page
defense defense 23. all of Defense 23. I
have nothing in front of me now it's
coming don't worry oh
all right so this is the second page of
that exhibit talks about 69 year old
male with htn hld We're not gonna go
through all of those things okay thank
you um
just got over a URI do you know what a
URI is
I do what is it upper respiratory
infection okay so you just got over that
yesterday you think at least according
to this record no cough just runny nose
um and upper respiratory symptoms this
is going to be his test for the cough
had not had a persistent cough Etc
weight gain thinks eating out too much
were you eating out too much
um Carlene and I
chose to eat out instead of cook okay
and not getting enough exercise yes
I think your thinks you've gotten old
all of a sudden Terry what does that
mean
did you tell your doctor that
you know um
I relate it to the URI if someone who's
just gotten over a
viral or bacterial infection either one
over two weeks with the cough and just
feeling worn out
I wouldn't doubt I wouldn't say
something like that and in fact it says
does not think depressed mood is good
just not doing the things you used to
but also things you're going to start
skiing again and re reinstate your gym
membership did you have a plan yeah I
absolutely did have a plan all right and
that that's all I need for that
um
talk about planning and I meant to ask
you about this before we we move on
um
do you have do you know what executive
functioning means
yes I well familiar with that term
actually what's your understanding of
what it means its ability to
to coordinate your actions through your
life to be able to
put things together make decisions about
them get things done
and be efficient and effective and be
able to multitask
and be effective and efficient and
effective
I'm going to move along
so Terry you were talking about
executive functioning you kind of gave a
what that means to you it looked like to
me from exhibit 23 you were able to make
a plan in your life and kind of follow
through with that have you been able to
do that since the ski accident
examples of not being able to do that
are
one of my collections I keep track of of
all the things I want to do and can't do
and there's
thousands there's at least 12 I guess I
should say 1200 or 1500 items on my
to-do list when I had I looked back to
2016 it repeats every day whatever
changes I make I look back to 2016 and
there were half a dozen dozen back there
which is Stephen covey's
rule right that's what you get done you
mark them as priorities and get them
done
it's just now continuous stuff I don't
get done and I can't tackle because I
can't figure it out it's just goofy the
things that I could do I was really
handy my dad was a handyman and I
learned and I have the tools
I have an example you know what I would
love to hear the example but I have made
a promise so I want to shift gears let's
do it
at some point
um
after the ski accident some time passed
and there was a press conference that
was held
yes yes I wasn't involved in that I
wasn't even your lawyer at the time
was the press conference your idea
absolutely not
do you know why the Press Conference was
held
is he waving his attorney-client
privilege because if he is I'm gonna
drive a bus through that what's the
what's the objection Council
he just violated his own attorney-client
privilege whose idea was objections
overruled as to relevance
what is your understanding as to why I
pray we understood and we agreed how
important it would be and I Hold On
I don't want you to discuss talk about
anything that you you talked about with
your counsel thank you okay did you have
an understanding why a Press Conference
was held
have a video of that particular
activity it would just be convincing and
would settle this beyond all doubt like
a GoPro exactly like a GoPro but all the
other cameras up there there had to be
somebody and that's what I knew in fact
I even looked
recently and put up a notice at Deer
Valley if anybody had a copy after that
press conference didn't go pro videos
service
has had
never
Terry did you cause the ski collision
with Miss pouter
absolutely not
I swear to my God and my family my other
father in Heaven it's like no no no
I did not why did you bring this lawsuit
to strike like religious Oaths here
sustained
disregard the last part of the last
response
why did you bring this lawsuit
you know I I realized after a period of
time
that no one believed
how serious my injuries were
just because I did wasn't out and
interacting continuously didn't mean
there was something any wrong with me I
really really wanted an opportunity
I knew there was damages and then there
was lots of insults added to that
singular incident lots of insults along
the way dozen of other times where
everything went contrary to my value
system
and I just went you know what
my daddy would say if you got the truth
you bring the truth don't let anybody
back you down
and that's what I felt I needed to do
and I'm here to prove that truth
only the with facts
thank you Mr
Owens
so I caught a cold
so I'm kind of keeping my distance from
people
where's that little microphone
oh there it is thank you
sorry I'm going to be wiping my nose a
little
and with this climate
and dry air I might have a bloody nose
yes
all right let's talk about a few things
so we're not going to get done with you
today
because we have witnesses this afternoon
but I think we can go till noon is that
all right with you
yeah sure whatever you like
did you ever say to me
I wrote I'm famous
because it's cool that I had a collision
with a celebrity
was that your thinking of the time
and you said yes do you deny it
I not if you have it on record no I
don't deny it I don't remember it but
well let's go to page 15. can you bring
that up move to publish the deposition
which is
why are we publishing
because the earlier denied it
it's just I'll overrule the object the
objection and permit that portion of the
deposition to be published may I ask
when this happened sure like one hour
ago two hours ago you told this jury
I've never thought it was cool that I
had a collision with a celebrity do you
recall that
yeah yes I guess I did say that
absolutely and that's not a true
statement is it
you have you have said this in your
deposition true
honestly I don't ever remember saying it
bring it up but I don't just I don't
doubt you I misspeak a lot
okay this is Page 15 line five through
eight so the words I'm famous this is my
question seem to say I think it's cool
that I had a collision with a celebrity
was that your thinking at the time and
your answer was yes I guess yes
now let's go to your weight you
testified today that you were 163 and
5'5 true yes I did and uh do you agree
that at your deposition you told me you
were 175 to 180 and 5 8.
yes or no
um
yes or no qualified a qualified yes
no I don't want to qualify did you tell
me that like I said how much do you
weigh and you said 175.80 how much did
you weigh and then you said five eight
how high are you how tall are you three
inches different
right I just found that out I didn't
realize you're telling me that you told
this jury
that the time of the accident you were
163 and 5'5 did you not like two hours
ago I did yes yes but you told me in
your deposition years ago that you were
170 to 180 and 5'8 true how many years
ago did we do this three years ago
I've lost a lot of weight I'm down to my
usual weight you know we're interested
not now in your weight today we're
interested in your weight on the day
thank you
I knew where that would you agree you
were five eight yes have you shrunk
three uh inches I couldn't believe it
either I wanted to argue because I think
I'm five eight yet you do have
degenerative back disease in those those
discs are just getting squeezed is that
why I have to say yes I've always been
five eight and a half and I knew I
shrunk a half an inch but
Mr Sanderson we're trying and Council
let's not speak on top of one another so
that we have a clear clean record
you're right that's your honor
when uh we talked about you being
unconscious and do you agree that
someone who's unconscious doesn't have a
stopwatch to figure out how long they
were actually unconscious I agree that's
true everything you've learned was from
Craig
after after the Collision no yeah that's
over vegan that's uh I'll withdraw it
because I I agree that's not everything
it's not everything right right as far
as level of
length of unconsciousness do you agree
that uh you you weren't stop watching
yourself I have no idea yeah and yet you
you did tell people
it varied over time first a few seconds
then five minutes then 10 minutes
you did that right
do you disagree
yes it did vary
and why did you do that why would you
say I don't know then it's a few seconds
then it's five minutes and then you told
your psychiatrist at the VA it was up to
10 minutes long why did you change
I had no idea and I was searching I I
really had no idea and I was trying to
answer I sometimes make that mistake
guessing but I really didn't know and it
was to try to get the attention of the
doctor do you remember telling me that
I don't
I I don't I don't know how to let's find
it
what's the date let's go to page 95.
which deposition one two or three one
they're they're all cumulative so the
page will tell you that page 95
starting at
uh
line seven
when you first tell your health care
providers a few seconds and then later
it turned into five minutes and then
later it turned into 10 minutes
do you know that you gave varying
answers to people
and then whenever you can pull it up
page page 95 yes
the witness says
and then can we go to the middle
paragraph
yes I do and that was referencing the
fact I personally did not know I was a
witness to I was not a witness to how
long I was unconscious
and so somebody told me it was two
seconds and somebody said it was 10
seconds 10 minutes
and so I was
I didn't know it was hard for me to say
and then next paragraph
it depends on my visit if I want to make
a deal out of it and that was the reason
for my visit then I might say for 10
minutes
I might pick the worst that's kind of
how we are we go to the doctor's
attention we excuse me we go to get the
doctor's attention about a specific
theme and it wasn't at that point how
long I was unconscious was not a point
of relevance for me
that's your testimony correct I'm
confused by those statements so
yes or no yes it is by the way when we
took your deposition there's there's a
lot of formality to it two you're placed
under oath just like the one you were
put on today yeah
and your council's present and you've
been able to you were able to talk to
them before
yes
and I think I had 11 hours or so of
deposition I can't really hear you sir
but my my question is you had your
advice of your counsel there yes and uh
I asked at the beginning of the
deposition is there any reason why you
can't give me your best testimony today
and you said no correct yes and I I even
told you I think that if you testify
differently at your deposition
then uh you'd you would in front of this
jury I would call it to their attention
do you recall this
yes
and you took an oath and you you then
had the opportunity to make any changes
to your deposition transcript is that
true
um yes and did you no I don't remember
making any changes I think I made two
with you
I said two Corrections and and that I
remembered
okay you didn't you didn't make some and
uh Council told you let's let's not
submit those I haven't looked at these
depositions at all
not at all
do you dispute that uh
well I heard you call Eric Christensen
a Deer Valley instructor for 40 years a
bully did you say that
I did say that yes and then he was
yelling at your face yes
I figured out
I didn't actually know that until and
we'll meet that we'll meet him at one
o'clock uh
deer Valley's known or at least puts
itself out there doesn't it as like the
most customer friendly they could
possibly be
do you agree I agree
were your skis on or off at the end of
the Collision do you know
absolutely they were on
okay so you do remember some things
after yes
and uh Craig
by the way you said you weren't here for
your daughters but you haven't been here
for several several statements right
yes it was more than just like I don't
want to make my daughters uncomfortable
you haven't been here for many I didn't
yeah and Sam Goldstein said part of the
reason is you don't take criticism well
do you agree with that statement
I always I always want to be a better
person and I thought I I thought I I
even tell my kids if I'm doing something
wrong tell me I want to be better
all right so do you agree or disagree
with this statement uh
Mr Sanderson does not take criticism
well
make sure that I've not been around
other humans as much as I have been in
the past
so it's hard for me to measure that
honestly I don't
do you agree that when Whitney came with
the toboggan
she asked you what happened and you said
I don't know
do you agree with that statement
um
I if if that's on the record I don't
disagree with it I don't remember that
particular part of our interaction I
just remember she said something to me
and
it's the first question right ski
patroller comes up
by the way you've hurt yourself before
skiing true
never needing never needing help right
before this incident though you injured
your knee I had when I first learned to
ski first year all right Beaver so you
don't dispute that the first thing
Whitney asked you was like how are you
and what happened do you agree those are
like the first two questions
I have no recollection of those
questions
I don't
I would think she would reach out to me
did you ever complain to Deer Valley
about Eric Christensen like I was
treated like a bully
I had a lot of time to think about it
yes or no I don't know if I did I wasn't
I think when I contacted Deer Valley I I
was just after I wanted to find out who
hit me and I wanted to copy the records
and I didn't bring it up yeah you never
once wrote to Deer Valley like hey
you're you're uh ski instructor is a
total SOB to me he treated me poorly
that's correct I didn't bring it up
because I did not want to cause some
anger from them I wanted to copy and
find out who hit me but seven years
later you're here saying he was terrible
to me just terrible
uh Ramon Craig Ramon said
words to the effect that
um
Christensen said to Ramon
your buddy took out Gwyneth Paltrow did
you hear those words I did you
personally heard them with your so now I
want to be clear because I'm not trying
to confuse you did you hear him when you
were on the ski no slope
uh
okay
and Ramon did not do anything
to try to set the record straight at
that point do you know anything about
that about who hit me correct when we
got down into the inside of that point
was my question on the mountain on the
mountain but in the shed I was okay
you said your skis were on after the
Collision do you recall your head being
downhill or uphill absolutely downhill I
was going down and absolutely so several
witnesses say the opposite and you
disagree I disagree absolutely because I
couldn't get up and where was gwyneth's
head gwyneth's head when she came to
arrest head down head up I have no idea
as far as I know she didn't exist
because you didn't see anything
I was out I had no idea everything else
is what I heard
did you tell Eric Christensen according
to his report that
she appeared right in front of me
yes or no no no so he just made that up
must have Deer Valley just uh falsified
a record
is that your opinion I never would have
said that I knew where it came from you
know you sued Deer Valley in this claim
Church
stained
and we're not dealing with any of that
today
true we're not dealing with the
projection relevance move to strike
sustain the the question is stricter in
the jury should disregard so your honor
I just want to be able to ask if if
you're willing is you're not suing Deer
Valley today your honor objection third
objection now move to strike again this
is
I hear you saying you were going you
were flying through the air after she
hit you did you say those words
today yes or no today today today I did
with regard to
um
relationships prior
you had two divorces true I did yes and
then was it about 10 years of just
dating various different other women
I guess I wouldn't know exactly wouldn't
be unreasonable maybe well I'm just
saying if the ACT incident occurred in
2016 when was your second divorce
about 10 years earlier
third
I'm thinking 30 years ago I'm thinking
all right so I mean uh it's nice that
Carlene you'd found a nice partner but
you were not engaged is that true we
were not and she was actually living
hundreds of miles away from you
we went back and forth it's three hours
four hours maybe
a couple hundred miles I think isn't it
St George
we'll let it we'll move on thank you
do you recall saying that you agreed
that saying I'm famous
was a crazy thing to say
agree absolutely it's not me it's I
don't buy into that but it was you right
just to be clear when you say it wasn't
me it it was in fact you it's the other
personality that's inhabiting my body
right now
and you blink Gwyneth Paltrow for that
do you recall having a kind of a stroke
event
like 10 years or so before the incident
yeah but that diagnosis had been changed
but it's an ischemic retinal occlusion
probably due to a migraine and you lost
your right eye in that I lost some
Vision in that is and that was one of
the reasons you were you retired
one of many yeah
um
in terms of your anger
do you agree you sought therapy for
Anger Management about 10 years ago
I don't or 15 years ago I guess 06 about
the time of your second divorce
I don't remember that purpose but it yes
I okay was I seeing a shrink or
so you can't ask me questions
unfortunately thank you oh I'm I'm
trying to have you say yes or no and
then we go to documents if we need to so
do you agree that you were seeing a
therapist at the VA for Anger Management
about 10 years even before the incident
only I honestly don't remember it but if
you say so I I believe you yeah I can't
testify so if you dispute it then we go
to the record and look at these records
I haven't 5 000 pages so you don't
dispute it
I don't okay
and
did you tell Shea that there was a GoPro
recording
absolutely not
do you recall at the exact time of this
event
going down the hill
you were sort of crossing over to the
right does that sound accurate no you
are always on the right yes okay
Christensen is going to testify this uh
this afternoon so we'll talk about that
and
um
do you agree in the five seconds or so
before the Collision
there was a female skier kind of
beginner-ish on your left
yes and do you agree that you actually
tilted your head to the left
to sort of confirm that you weren't
going to hit her that she would be okay
after the accident five seconds before
the before no
did you so testify ever I I saw her when
I re what I I don't know what I remember
is I always saw her she was a little
uncomfortable and I gave her a little
more room just kind of what you do and
dashing on your right and did you hit
did you turn because of your right eye
is blind no did you turn toward her
no reason to look you did not no okay
we'll pull that up probably at our next
visit
you texted about Whitney the toboggan
person how how happy you were with her
true I did yes give her full credit and
we've both read it it's pretty
articulate pretty detailed right it is
you knew you were being subjected to
a brain test
like a memory test well I'm not
okay go ahead right didn't didn't you
tell us that when she said I want you to
remember some things yeah so yes
absolutely okay you knew you were you
were being subject to a brain oh memory
test I've never focused so hard and you
came through with flying colors right do
you do them all I did
remember president Trump said they gave
me five things to remember and I got
them all do you remember this
I don't
I don't pay attention I'm sustained
you called her a sweetheart and then she
entertained you and that was all really
within a half hour of the incident
a half hour of the Collision is that
true I don't remember the time frame
Carlene may have been there by then I
don't know she was helpful but it was at
the base where the toboggan went down to
yes that was uh that wasn't well tell me
is that at the bottom of Deer Valley or
is that a mid-level clinic I think I
think all right
is there a picture of you two in a
wheelchair smiling
do you remember that picture I haven't
seen it ever
remember she didn't know
Shea mentioned it that there was a
picture of you and maybe it was at the
InstaCare do you remember anyone in any
picture of you in the InstaCare in a
wheelchair smiling no
no okay and I asked you about and you
said I just smiled because they told me
uh somebody says someone said smile and
you smiled does this ring a bell from
your deposition it does not I okay but
that's
so you took a picture of Whitney right I
did composed that very nice email with
all the details and then you sent it to
your group
probably I don't say I composed it I
could have had Carlene's help she may
have been there then and that's well you
did it though right you you came up with
those exact words Carlene didn't do that
I may have helped her well she doesn't
know she grew up in Michigan that she's
uh won the
Deer Valley Collision or the Deer Valley
grand whatever race right that's right
all right she doesn't know that
do you think Carlene was present
at the Deer Valley Clinic I know she no
she wasn't at the Deer Valley Clinic no
absolutely not okay no when we got home
misunderstood she was on her way
do you remember Carlene
didn't buy into this was that your
quotes in terms of your uh did you say
those words just like an hour or two ago
Carly didn't buy into what Mr Owens do
you remember saying those words she
wasn't buying into this what was the
question it was uh why your relationship
with her deteriorated after the
Collision
I
I misspoke I absolutely absolutely
I'm not sure I understand that
to be clear on that issue and I realized
I'm jumping around but I'm keeping an
eye on the clock did you
um
with regard to Carlene it sounds like
you shut it down you shut the
relationship down is that true
I made a very strong statement that she
was going to be better off without me
yes
and you told her that yes so Carlene was
here a couple days ago and said I I he
never told me
did you tell her
I had no idea I told her what I said and
what I said what I what I thought I
shared was Carly and I you got to run I
don't want you stuck with me
and I know you would stay by me I know
she
knows so your next then you started
calling your daughters it sounds like
even before the I'm famous thing is that
true
I don't remember that honestly uh Shay
said she took a call from you about six
something okay so about six hours later
okay okay have you ever read her
depositions no by the way or Jenny's I
told him I wouldn't
and they had even expressed like Hey Dad
we're kind of concerned
because
we got to talk about
you and how you were growing up and
things and we're kind of concerned that
it will hurt your feelings do you recall
this
I didn't know why but they knew I don't
remember them telling me that I just I
decided that before
all right so we got you're at the clinic
you take a picture this is at this on
the Deer Valley Hill you take a picture
of Ramon and one of the other skiers and
they're all smiles did you know that
um boy that's
a little bit a little bit I do kind of
remember that can you bring up the
picture right now
sure yeah I believe that did happen and
uh I don't remember them being smiling
Smiles okay we'll pull it up here okay
and do you have the number D I'm gonna
find it one second
d87 moved to admit
I think it was it is go ahead d87
received do you remember and I can give
you a hard binder if you want it looks
like the monitor's working I do
recognize that you took this picture
I recognize a picture and I probably did
take it all right
smile you know
when you went uh to
the InstaCare do you have a personal
memory of that
I really don't I I didn't I don't
remember if I had an x-ray it's like
okay I think the physician assistance
coming tomorrow but he wrote no no signs
of confusion do you dispute that no
no I don't wasn't there not him
do you agree that in your post Collision
talk with shea about six hours after the
incident you told her I'm okay
that would be me I my parents didn't
find out a divorce until the last day I
don't want to put them through that
misery I don't share my information all
right so let me I think that's a yes but
I'm going to re-ask it because we need
to get it clear
at six o'clock just hours six hours
after the Collision did you tell your
daughter Shea I'm okay
yes yes
thank you
overruled and then on the hill
on the hill itself with the accident
having occurred just in the prior
minutes
do you agree that someone asked you are
you okay
that is absolutely Beyond a doubt wrong
no one spoke to me when I was needing
help no one stopped no one so your
testimony is Eric Christensen just sat
there and looked at an unconscious man
for several minutes is that your
testimony yes she never said one word to
me that I recall maybe when he got me up
so Ramon although he did try to change
his deposition
did say that at one point you said I'm
okay do you dispute it I dispute it now
never dispute it you have to know
everything you said
right like I know everything I said and
I didn't say it
are you saying you have a perfect memory
of what you said
on that hill just after the Collision
yes or no I knew an argumentative
it's not argumentative overruled yes or
no
um say yes or no please
question again please yes
do you agree
that uh
you do not have a perfect memory of what
you told others
after in the one two minutes three
minutes after the Collision
or do you have a perfect memory well
that word is so ultimate perfect right
that answer would be no it's not perfect
okay so it's possible you said for
instance Eric Christensen is going to
testify first witness this afternoon
that you told them I'm okay do you
dispute it
I disputed I never felt safe and like
anybody was there to help me and then I
would not have said it he's about to
testify that not only he was there but a
ski patroller Duo came over one of them
came over and said do you guys need any
help or words to that effect
and that you consulted with Ramon
and then said no
do you dispute it
I absolutely would have said no I never
said safe so I don't want to say what I
would have said I want to know if you
remember do you remember that no I don't
remember in fact you don't even remember
that ski patrollers came by true no I do
not remember that yeah ever
we talked about your right eye but your
left eye also has uh some some severe
vision loss is that true
is she 20 20 in that eye
did you have a cataract in that eye I
did and that cataract's been removed
since the ski Collision yes
uh there's a report on February 4 2015.
his vision and his left eye is
decreasing or blind in right eye
was your left eye decreasing one year
before the ski Collision increasing in
visual Acuity or sorry prescription
decreasing was your left eye decreasing
yes getting less need for prescription
but not the visual acuity now in
addition to your stroke you also had a
your heart was not perfect do you agree
before the ski Collision
perfect of course I
couldn't agree with the word perfect no
palpitation yet palpitations agreed Adam
most of my life yeah how many years
40 years probably and what's the lay
term for palpitation is it just um it's
called a usual beat it's it's just a
little out of sync that happens when I'm
pretty tired or if I've been on the
treadmill too long or running too long
and hard then then it will get a little
funny it's called pcvs so it's your your
Beats off is that fair to say yeah but
it's nothing yeah I notice it doesn't
change okay and but you are on two
different uh high blood pressure
medications does that sound right yes
and that's because one didn't one wasn't
adequate you needed both
we're going to is I can explain if you
want your honor but this this event
later
witnesses that to which this forms part
of their opinion
sure his overall health yes
explain that his
instructed by this act
your honor he says this is utterly
changed his life
just a minute
Council would you approach please
afternoon recess at this time in return
at 1 30. thank you
may be seated so Council
consistent with the motion and Lemony
ruling that the court gave at the before
trial
um
Mr Sanderson you can certainly step down
there there's a there there were there's
a laundry list of medical issues and
medical issues if they're relevant they
absolutely should come in if they're not
relevant they should not come in so
there will need to be I mean I need I
need from you an assurance that this is
a conditional relevance uh situation and
and that you will tie in the relevance
later and not just a vague statement
from an expert that this guy had a lot
of health problems before I mean I need
to know it needs to be tied in so maybe
you want to look at the reports or
depositions to make sure that whatever
it is that you're examining this witness
on will be tied in later by a medical
expert as to the relevance either before
or after I mean either one of those
would be relevant James is sort of on
the damages and so I'll defer to him on
the specifics but we are talking when
they say it's utterly ruined my life
that's we're talking about the whole
package and aging is one of the primary
just normal aging is one of the primary
issues for our experts and so uh we got
to look at the whole package not how
about this heart thing and how about
this prostate thing and how about this
um
where we will argue and our experts will
back it is that that's the reason he is
kind of slowly deteriorating Progressive
aging
okay so take a look at what the opinions
will be and if they're if you feel as
though they're tied in
um then you can go into those areas
thank you it seemed like there was one
other issue okay I just want to kind of
put this on the stand so I had I had
seven Witnesses lined up I was supposed
to take over the case this morning at 9
00 A.M
many are out of state
plaintiffs
Council I don't dispute everyone's
working hard but it has significantly
thrown off my witness list to the point
that I'm actually having to cancel
Witnesses and so that we can read their
transcripts
and some people some of our experts in
particular flying in out of state I can
testify during this small window and
um
I lost as of last night they were going
to be done at 10 then it was 11 and uh
they still haven't rested
weather true I guess I'm not really
blaming people except for
I still don't have the case they're not
ready to rest
multiple assurances that they were going
to rest on Friday
thank you okay and also for the record
the court didn't issue an order
concerning you know when one case one
must be rested in one other
must be rested is I've been leaving it
up to council to work that out and I
from my perspective it looks like
everyone's doing the best they can
it's hard when I have like kids flying
in
understand
you want any response to that or should
we just hold our peace
why don't we take lunch
be back at 1 30.
you're getting a printout for the amount
of trial time that's been used so far
as soon as we get to a working printer
maybe seated
calling Sanderson versus Paltrow looks
like not quite everyone's present
as soon as you are ready for the jury
let me know
foreign
hours up here
yeah
ready for the jury Council
all right we're ready
thank you
foreign
thank you and good afternoon Mr
Sanderson would you please take the
retake the witness stand
oh okay
sure
your Valley people lined up
um I would like to continue my
questioning of Mr sanderson's but at a
different time
okay
it's the next witness Eric Christensen
Mr Christensen
if you could come right up here sir
you are about to give in the case now
before the court will be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
shall help you God
thank you can have seed good afternoon
sir just right around here and there's
the chair
and the left hand armrest has been
acting up again
sorry I have a cold
sir one more one more thing would you
please State your full name and spell
all the words
middle name also
my name is Eric Paul Christensen
e-r-i-c-p-a-u-l-c-h-r-i-s-t-i-a-n-s-e-n
um let's introduce yourself what city do
you live in I live in Camas okay and uh
married kids I have two children they're
both in their 30s I have two
grandchildren
and uh skiing has been a big part of
your life is that fair it has been I've
been a ski instructor for 44 years 39 of
those at Deer Valley
and uh remind I can think of what a ski
instructor is but just comment a little
further on that would you what is a ski
instructor
once I came to Deer Valley
um I went through both of my levels of
certification there's three now but uh
they've added one on the front end
but we're members of the professional
ski instructors of America we happen to
be in the Intermountain division
we I'm certified to ski to teach all
levels from you know young kids all the
way through adults from never ever never
been on skis through experts
okay I talked to your wife she's been in
the ski industry 50 years too
she actually receives her 50-year
she just received her 50-year level
three pin yes and but during that time
she spent 32 years as a patroller at
Park City Mountain Resort
she was a weekend patroller you
mentioned level three uh is three good
yes there it used to be called associate
in full and then they they change it
they added a bronze pin at the front end
and so it went level one level two level
three and so the the former full
certified is now called level three
certified
so I'm gonna ask James to show you
um
a 20-second animation may I do that your
honor
will you approach the bench sure
so objection over overruled well I I'm
holding it in advance right now until
you show the witness the animation
so make James approach the witness
or plaintiff's council needs to see
what's being shown you can come up here
also
so Mr Christensen James is going to run
a 20-second animation for you okay
for the record this is the sixth number
six true
there's no sound tell please tell me
when it's over
have you reviewed that yes okay uh can I
have plaintiff's council go back will
that help you explain your testimony to
the jury
yes it will
will it help explain the position of the
parties at the time of the accident
yes
does it help explain your Recollections
of the events
from yes it does is it substantially
similar to your recollection of the
events on the date in question yes it is
so your honor I moved to publish
this animation to the jury as a
demonstrative exhibit
uh plaintiff objects the demonstrative
is not illustrative of the
Witnesses Viewpoint and uh if you
wouldn't mind your honor I'd like to
have another sidebar
okay the motion is granted the animation
number six will be received for
demonstrative purposes and if the jury
will recall jury instruction number 18
addresses evidence like this
certain charts and summaries in this
case an animation
sometimes referred to as demonstrative
exhibits will be shown to you to help
explain the evidence however these
charts and summaries and in this case an
illustration or a
animation are not themselves evidence
and you will not have them in the Jury
Room with you when you deliberate you
may consider them to the extent that
they correctly reflect the evidence
all right
let's play the animation and then we're
going to go back and talk about it is
this from your Viewpoint this one would
be from my viewpoint yes and let's be
clear this is not a GoPro video no this
is a creation it's not an actual video
correct that is correct all right so
this is from is if you had a camera on
your forehead at the time
uh does this sort of illustrate your
testimony
it will
it's been a minute
likes Foundation
okay let's play the video
all right we're going to take this kind
of piece by piece let's go to the very
beginning do you know the bandana run
very well how many times have you skied
that
well
um
I've been at Deer Valley for uh 40 years
actually I would say that the bandana
run has been there for about 30 of those
and it is the only or access that goes
directly from
Flagstaff Mountain
to the Empire area
and uh do you recognize
this for instance this little cabin
there on the left
oh yes
uh what is it a private home it's a
private home do you recognize those and
I have a little laser here if I'm doing
this right
do you see those buckets right there
yeah those are green foam tubes that
cover up the snow making
there's water and air or Water and
Electric depending on what type of
system they have and uh does that
provide some landmark in where this
Collision occurred it does okay was it
essentially across from them
uh where the Collision occurred was that
sort of across from the snow equipment
uh it would be in that general area yes
okay and then there's some people here
so who's the orange the guy in the
orange that would represent Moses All
right so let's back up
um were you hired by Miss Paltrow to
Paltrow excuse me to help Moses that day
yes and had you helped him before this
was the third time I had skied with them
uh twice in the previous year and then
this trip on this year would you lie for
Guana today no
um
are you testifying truthfully today yes
I am
by the way you were called a bully this
morning have you ever bullied a guest at
Deer Valley
Deer Valley takes
their guests very seriously and if an
instructor is confident uh you know has
a confrontation with a guest
we don't last
we were supposed to be polite to
everyone and I was applied to Mr
Sanderson that day and have you been
polite to every guest in 40 years
I've never had a reason not to be so yes
were you a bully to Mr Sanderson I was
not
is that a ridiculous claim I I feel that
it is yes and you were personally named
in this
very lawsuit
sustained as to relevance
to credibility I believe
I'll follow your order okay
um
there's been an allegation just this
morning
that you stood by and yelled at an
unconscious man for two or more minutes
uh did you
I'm asking him to comment on that it's a
prefer to as a preparatory statement
it's fine overruled did you do that I
did not
um no one was ever unconscious during
that period of time
um
uh where do you want me to start yes
it's a big story okay okay who who are
these two people on the uh animation
those would represent apple and
um also Carrie Oaks another instructor
all right so they were a little head is
that fair they were in the proximity I
can't tell you for sure exactly where
they were but we were all in the same
proximity and uh
all right do you actually recognize
recognizing this as an animation but
does it uh
illustrate well
the geography of the actual run it does
do you know anything about like a
special photographer going up and
actually contouring the the product the
Run well it is of what I've been told it
is an actual photograph of the Run
uh so and the uh this was a clear day it
was
and that's uh do you know whether this
was the actual
month in day not the year of the actual
incident itself like this is literally
the day
like February 26th right I was told that
the other day okay you don't personally
know that no okay all right
um
the title of this image is uh
christensen's POV point of view and uh
let's let's run it and then James I'll
ask you to stop at some point
okay let's stop
who is that
that would represent Mr Sanderson all
right why why is it you would look up to
see someone like Mr Sanderson
well when you're working with students
especially if they're children you're
always looking around it's very much
like driving you're aware of everything
around you
um the one thing this animation does not
show is I actually watched him make
several turns down and that's what
caught my eye and so uh he Mr Sanderson
has some very strong skiing skills
because he was skiing edge to edge
rolling in skis an intermediate skier
skids much more but he was skiing edge
to edge and he was making what we would
refer to as GS giant slums turns which
basically means that they're round and
large and fairly fast okay and comment
on Moses's ability Moses it was I think
it was maybe his fourth time I he went
to Big Bear one day from my
understanding and then he had skied a
few days with me on one trip a couple of
days on a second trip and this was his
first day of this trip so he did not
have a lot of experience he was nine
years old
and so he was still in a wedge and so we
were skiing very slow we were skiing on
the side of the Run
and uh
comment on gornos uh
skill level Gwyneth is a strong
intermediate skier and
she was skiing skiers right while we
were on skiers left and one of the
things that's interesting is that she
was making short radius turns now when
we teach people how to be safe one of
the things that we do is we try to teach
them to ski not right down the middle of
the run because that's where all the
traffic is but if they can ski a shorter
radius turn on the side that means
they're in a narrower Corridor it also
means that they are out of the line of
traffic and Uphill skiers who are faster
can watch and anticipate them and and
miss them and that's what she was doing
she was actually skiing short radius
turns on the skiers right right next to
the edge
jump beyond your background so when it's
not ski season what do you do for a
living
I also teach at the winter sports school
it's a high school that was set up for
winter athletes and so we start in April
and about the second week of April and
then graduation will be the week before
Thanksgiving and so the students get an
academic education but they also get
five months off during the winter to
work on their sport
I think I mentioned that your wife is a
level three instructor are you a level
three instructor yes I am and is that
the highest level it is and highest mean
highest means most advanced then it's
correct okay
all right let's let's run the video just
a little bit more
okay let's stop who is
you know
say again who all these people are would
you who's that on the on the far end on
on the far end that would be uh Miss
Paltrow okay
and let's go a little further
now
let's stop
okay all right
Craig Ramon said when he heard a sound
he turned is that what you did
well of course when I heard a scream
that's when I looked back he's claimed
to be the only eyewitness who
essentially heard and turned but you
also heard and turned is that right that
is correct and was Ramon immediately on
the scene he was not
um
what happened was I had been watching Mr
Sanderson skied down and because I was
aware of my students on that side but as
soon as he passed us I looked back at
Moses and it was a mere moments after
that that we heard this uh The Scream
all right so
um
whenever you say a pronoun like he okay
ask you to clarify sorry about that all
right so just say that last sentence
again would do with using the name okay
so Mr Sanderson was skiing down making
fairly large turns and he had
accumulated a fair amount of speed
I watched him and while I was watching
my kids I was paying attention to both
and as soon as he passed us and I wasn't
concerned with him hitting us
then I turned back towards Moses and but
at that point he was very close to miss
Paltrow
and I looked away I did not actually see
the Collision but I heard her scream and
that's when I looked up but Ramon was
not on the scene for how many seconds I
would say at least 45 seconds I mean uh
Miss Paltrow was already up on her feet
we were getting Mr Sanderson up on his
feet
he was he was very late to the scene I
would just assume that he was not as
fast a skier as Mr Sanderson was all
right so let's be clear did you
literally see the moment of impact I did
not all right
did you hear and turn
I did hear and I turned and that by that
time they're already moving on the
ground and who's on top
Miss Paltrow is on top all right and uh
let's finish running the video if you
don't mind
so is this you skiing over to them it is
is this more or less what you saw pretty
much they were below me so the first
thing I did was I turned to Carrie and I
said I asked her to take Moses and I
said I'm going to go over to see what
happened and at that point I traversed
across they were below me and so I
didn't have to skate or anything I just
did you hear uh Miss Paltrow say
anything
when I got there
yeah okay
uh when I got to the scene uh they were
she was talking and uh a little bit
upset
um
they were both talking the first thing I
did was I took off my skis and I moved
around on the
would have been the right hand side
and she was they both had their heads
uphill
both sets of skis were still on both she
and Mr Sanderson
and uh their skis were below them
and they were basically lying pretty
much on their backs okay and
um I think Ramon
said that their heads were downhill do
you agree or disagree I disagree
and you even smiled and why did you
smile
well for one thing he wasn't there at
that time
but no they were
you know I don't know how to describe it
with my arms but you know they were on
the slope and she was underneath and he
was on top of her and uh he also Ramon
said that uh
Mr Sanderson was a spread eagle pointing
downhill Did You observe that I never
observed that you would have you would
have remembered that wouldn't you have
well of course
okay and then when you first came over
then
I heard you say
Gwyneth was upset
yeah is that the first thing you heard
out of their mouths
it's been long enough excuse me it's
been long enough ago that I can't give
you you know an exact you know
play-by-play of who said what when I do
know certain statements were made okay
and uh
did you hear
Mr Sanderson say anything during the
entire incident oh of course what were
those things well the first he was
apologizing to her
you heard that with your engineers yes I
did
and um but the when they started
responding to my questions the first
thing I needed to do is get their skis
off it's very hard to get up
on any slope with your skis on a lot
easier to take them off but also they
were entwined with each other I mean
they were kind of you know tangled up
with each other and so the the best
thing to do was to get their skis off
that's the safest thing to do and so she
was on top and so I think you might have
said at some point
Gwyneth was underneath but she was on
top that's her test did I yeah she I
didn't know I'm sorry did I get that
back with my partner I said you did I
didn't catch that just be clear okay who
was on top she was on top okay Mr
Sanderson was on the slope lying down
and she was on top of of him okay I'm
sorry and their skis were intermixed and
their skis were kind of tangled up with
each other with her legs okay first
thing you did I heard you say you took
removed her skis because she was on top
it's the only way I could do it okay and
help her sort of separate right I gave
her my arm and helped her up and then I
immediately went and helped get Mr
Sanderson skis off
and then I would have I put it my arm
out and helped him up also did you just
grab him and jerk them up onto his feet
of course not how do you do that
that would have hurt my back I'm too old
to do things like that no I just simply
gave him my R to help him get up you
heard him say what words in terms of the
apology
he said when she was talking to him he
simply said I'm sorry I'm sorry but then
he also made a statement about she just
appeared in front of me
okay you remember those words yes what
was that indicate to you in terms of who
was the uphill skier well what indicates
that he was the Upper Hill skier is that
I witnessed him coming much faster than
anybody else on the slope coming down
the hill and I looked away mere moments
before the impact so that's number one
why he would be the uphill skier the
other thing is that it would be very
difficult to be underneath her
if he hadn't hit her from behind
and explain well
um projection Foundation
I don't know what that means
he didn't see it
I'll allow Ace okay constructionist go
ahead what I did just a second overruled
I think okay he was there his perception
what I did see is everything leading up
to it and the immediate aftermath so I
cannot speak to the actual Collision but
I can speak to what I saw immediately
before and the aftermath right but I
think you told me at one point like if a
soccer player takes out someone's legs
uh they're underneath yes it would it
would be very similar to that it's a
situation where it would be almost
impossible to be in front of Miss
Paltrow and then end up underneath her
so I heard a few things if if we're
trying to outline things you heard from
Mr sanderson's own mouth she appeared
right in front of me yes that is correct
I'm sorry I'm sorry yes he was not real
talkative to be honest with you how
about
did you ask him are you okay I had to
that's the whole time I'm removing skis
and and getting ready to help them up
I'm asking are you okay are you okay so
the answer did you ask him if he was
okay I did and he was affirmative he
said yes
all right
and uh
did a ski patrol Duo come by they did
there's a just a few minutes later than
that now by this time
Mr Ramon has arrived on the scene
and so two patrollers are just making a
ski buy and one of them came up to us
and said you guys do you need any help
and Mr Ramon Mr Sanderson spoke to each
other I was still kneeling on the snow
you know getting their skis ready and
um whatever they said they turned to the
patroller and said no we don't need help
all right so they talk to each other
quietly out of your hearing that is
correct and did you try to influence
them like say no say no of course not
okay that's ridiculous yes it is and
what did they say who spoke
um who declined help I would assume it
was Mr Sanderson but they looked
directly at the patroller and refused
help all right
if they had said
I'm not okay if Mr Sanderson said
I am not okay what happened well what
happened that would have changed the
entire situation
people on a ski slope have minor bumps
and things constantly
um
maybe you could rephrase the question as
phrased it is speculation
well what have you observed over 50 40
some years 44 years
um
with regard to skier collisions okay
sustained
have you uh yourself I can answer the
original question so the judge sustained
it so I'm rephrasing my question I'm
just wondering uh have you personally
come across skiers who have collided
before
yes and just comment on what you've
observed
if they're
overruled
if they are both in a situation where
they each claim they're okay typically
the two skiers part ways and ski off
if anyone is hurt now it's a tolls a
different scenario and Patrol will have
to be called
um
statements will be taken
Patrol will assess how much injury there
is whether they need to be taken out of
Toboggan or whatever
and so Patrol takes over at that point
and we become simply Witnesses all right
um
was this important to you to know the
answer to that question whether the
skier from his own mouth felt he was
okay well of course because if these if
either skier had said oh I'm hurt I need
assistance
that would have changed everything
okay that would have you know made it so
we would have all stayed on the scene
and uh if Mr Ramon and Mr Sanderson had
said to the ski patrol person
we need assistance would that have
changed anything I would have been there
the whole time yes okay
going to testified essentially she said
you just skied into my effing back
all right
did Mr Sanderson say anything like that
no he did not what did he say she
appeared right in front of me he
appeared she appeared right in front of
me
you didn't know that he had a blind eye
at that time no I did not
okay uh your honor I'm now gonna have
James show an additional uh just to the
witness himself an additional anime
approach the bench on that
thank you for your patience thank you
Mr sander excuse me James is going to
show you a another
um animation it's also about 20 seconds
and also it does not have sound and this
is going to be number one and it's from
what view James
looking uphill
number one
foreign
by the way
I wanted to introduce the the fact that
deer Valley's lawyer is here is that
true
far right
you're right my right I see him and I
don't represent you is that true that is
correct
um okay
of course maybe finish laying your
foundation let's let's do that please so
you've had a chance now to review what
we're going to call video number one
okay that's correct will that help you
explain your testimony to the jury it
will and will it help explain the
positioning of the parties at the time
of the accident yes and
if I interrupted you go ahead objection
move to strike that's opinion evidence
overruled and so this animation will be
received again for demonstrative
purposes not as evidence but to
illustrate this witness testimony does
it help explain your recollection of the
events
yes is it substantially perfect excuse
me substantially similar to your
recommendation or recollection of the
events on The Dating question it is very
similar yes so uh I will ask for
permission now to publish this to the
jury as a demonstrative exhibit
where I've indicated
to me to stop it okay
um
do you see all these people identified
the woman on the left top left Did You
observe her uh Mr Sanderson did but I'm
doing a little laser did you personally
observe that person
I saw her yes she was viewed described
by Mr Sanderson as sort of a beginner
more beginner person that he did not
want to hit
okay what do you recall I don't recall
much because she was not an uh a skier
that I was concerned with she was on the
other side of the Run
um I did see her but she was not skiing
fast
so I really didn't pay much attention to
her and then on this side is there a bit
of a little Cliff or Ridge here well
skiers right it's not a cliff but it is
a drop-off
as most ski runs they're created with
bulldozers and machinery and to create a
run and so there's always an edge from
the man-made feature and do you
recognize these are these the snow
making equipment buckets on the right
right it's basically utilities here it
would be one would contain water and one
would contain compressed air and at the
top of this run as a on this exhibit is
that the very top of the entire run of
the bandana run yes you can see a lift
up in the upper left hand corner that
would be the Ruby lift that's like if
you're improved you're not a robot I
wouldn't have missed I would have missed
that actually okay okay then it says
Paltrow is that brown
uh okay
Mrs Sanderson is identified in blue do
you see that yes Christensen is that you
kind of represented okay yes
is an orange Under This
you with me yes Carrie Oaks is she the
instructor for Apple that is correct all
right
by the way plaintiff's asserted in their
opening that Miss pal throw was Reckless
and dangerous on this hill Did You
observe that not at all
all right let's run through this from
start to end or start till the crash so
we're gonna stop right before the crash
um
okay
can we do it just a little longer to see
where they're
well let's talk let's talk to you so
when you turned your head we want to we
want to fast forward over that
so uh you tell us there's
there's squenneth and there's
Sanderson
uh
did you see a little bit more of this or
was this the end of what you saw
I I saw a little bit more of this and
um can we go slow motion until he says I
want you to say stop okay okay the judge
is the governing person here but uh can
we you say stop when you no longer
observe something is that okay your
honor thank you
okay
once he was below us
okay so he's now he's heading back I was
Ace right there okay you turned away and
then
um at some point you looked you came
over
and so James if there's a way to uh were
they at a complete stop when you came
over yes they were and so is there a way
James to move this to when they're at a
complete stop
he's gonna put it back on here okay all
right uh
this is you on the right is that that
would be correct and then
they've now collided they're pretty
close to the edge there would you agree
yes because as I walked around I was
actually standing below
the lift sorry I mean below the Run
slightly and there's the buckets right
there right right those are the are the
tubes and now can we play the remainder
thank you and uh Moses
uh
is gonna say he essentially followed you
over uh
do you have any and heard something I'm
just wondering okay
um
your honor should rule sustained okay
okay
um
okay okay
Did You observe
uh Gwyneth
uh
upset
yes she was upset comment on that would
you
when you're skiing you don't expect to
be
taken out because that happens very fast
we cannot look behind you now I have I'm
in the habit of always looking uphill
because quite often Mike responsive
sustained
okay just
um let's be a little more precise on the
question was Gwyneth upset
Gwyneth was upset what did You observe
as I came across uh she was speaking to
Mr Sanderson
once again the first things I did was
ask if everyone was okay did he's with
did she yell at him
I don't know that she yelled I remember
her that she was speaking of quite
sharply and but I don't know that I
would say she yelled I I can't recall
that
in your experience is it the the person
who hit that says who hits the other
that says I'm sorry objection overbroad
over over
overruled go ahead
who who apologizes typically
usually the person who runs into the
other person is the first to apologize
and who's mad who's usually mad excuse
me objection that uh
speculation vague
overruled so who's usually mad
uh usually a person that feels like they
were the victim okay is upset
and have you seen collisions where
there's a there's a dispute like you did
it no you did it have you been there
that happens from time to time was there
any dispute between these two
among what you saw and heard from them
Mr Sanderson never said you ran into me
or anything of that nature so was there
any dispute
to investigate that like who's telling
the truth not at that time and did Ramon
by the way did he ever come to you and
say like hey I saw it
and she hit him he did not he never said
a word to you right no
all right uh
let's go
to the next uh
James is going to come show you another
one so we I moved to admit this one I
believe and it was as received we
reserve our objections your honor yes
and James do you mind thank you
would you just approach before you do
that
next 10 minutes
sure okay let's take a recess now well
they get ready for us all right
thank you we'll take five minutes
the jury's assembling
sure
so there are a total of seven uh
animations we we wanted to get in six
through him
uh your honor has mentioned concerns
with repetition and we'll show one as
asked that we show just one more
um I will represent that he he will
establish foundation for all of them for
the portions he saw what I wouldn't want
is because we have to hurry we only do
the three and then they object the plane
of subject test getting in the other
three to four
so I'm I'm all for
not repeating myself but there are
different views so I I kind of moved to
publish all of them
okay and I think I've made my ruling
that at least you know each one of these
any animation is a demonstrative exhibit
and it's illustrative of a witness's
testimony not of a case
and right now we've had two come in for
this witness well it looks like we may
get one more or want a portion of it
anyway and all I can do is say that I'll
take the other animations as they come
as demonstrative of a Witnesses
testimony if they are
I think we could move very quickly
through them if they'll just agree that
he'll say the exact same thing for each
one of them but which I don't think
would be repetitive but
uh may I ask him just that you've
reviewed all of them and they've all fit
these Five Points
but we're only going to address one
I mean
it's rep it's repetitious with this
witness so right we're only going to
show one but can I establish the
foundation for each of like the the
other four in Mass
there's an agreement to that effect
otherwise you'll have to go through the
normal process
and I'm not hearing what these people
say
all right so I do feel like I'm
you can't you can't do it but they won't
agree that if we did it we could do it
if if uh people are following me and it
was it was raised pre-trial in an effort
to smooth things out and I think it has
helped dramatically
um
and I'm not I haven't changed my ruling
from what I did at the pre-trial so I
haven't changed my mind on it either
okay we're ready for the jury
let me just clarify for the record Mr
Owens if you give me just a minute the
um the last animation which was called
the looking up hill animation number one
demonstrative exhibit
was received for the monster purposes
from zero to eight
I believe that's eight seconds and then
from 17 to 22.
okay we're going to show one more video
okay
by the way if you reviewed all seven
videos I have yes and uh as to we're
only going to look at one but do they
all help explain your testimony to the
church
or uh Mr Owens already ruled on that
okay um we're only going to talk now
about uh the overview
okay
overhead thank you can Mr uh Egan show
the witness
that yes please animation thank you
this is also about 20 seconds it's also
no sound
probably the same spots again same
sentence
synchronized yeah they're all the same
so like red as he turned right
in the 17 to 22 yeah
yeah saying
but you're in the same spot keep track
of the uh
have you had an opportunity to review
the animation uh from the overhead
Viewpoint yes I have and just so you
know uh since you did not see the
accident itself the moment of impact
we're going to skip over that part okay
and so like you did with the other one
we want you to tell us when to stop
when you stopped viewing something uh
well the video I should say the
animation you just saw will it help you
explain your testimony to the jury it
should yes
overruled yes it will
it help explain the position of the
parties at the time of the accident
that is probably the most important part
yes does it help explain your
recollection of the events yes it does
is it substantially similar to your
recollection of the events on the date
in question it is so move to publish of
this to the jury as a demonstrated
exhibit do you understand objections
also it lacks Foundation because
he can't possibly know what to view from
whatever 50 feet above is
it's received for demonstrative purposes
only not as evidence but as illustrative
once again what number is
thank you do you see the buckets in the
top right
this is missing buckets does that help
you in providing a landmark for where we
are it does now you weren't flying over
this in a helicopter looking down right
that is correct and uh the animation
isn't perfect do you agree it's not as
good as as if we had had a drone
yes the animation shows everything
almost in slow motion and the events
were much more
Dynamic okay but as far as positioning
it's very good all right let's show the
uh the video and James is gonna jump
over will you tell us when to stop
okay let's stop for a minute and just
Orient everyone
okay at the top in yellow is uh Miss
Oaks the ski instructor is that true
Crypt then Apple and purple that's uh
gwyneth's daughter true
correct Moses gwinna's son right correct
then we're you're just out of the screen
yeah I'm on the screen here
oh yeah our screen's just a text you're
about to come in and then a woman is uh
what's been viewed to as a kind of a
more beginner
skier and you you observed her
I observed her but didn't pay a lot of
attention to me and Mr Sanderson will
talk about her and then miss miss pal
throw okay let's proceed
okay let's stop just for a minute Mr
Sanderson is over here did you observe
him making turns yes I did what kind of
turns
they were large radius
overruled
they were large radius turns
edge to edge quite Dynamic what's the
word radius mean radius is from the
center of what would be a circle to the
outside of the circle and that's the arc
that your turn makes
so big or small he was making fairly
large radius turns and what kind of
turns was Gwyneth making
she was making a shorter radius turn so
she was in a very narrow Corridor and he
was we use the term carpet to carpet
which means that you ski from one side
to the opposite side as you make your
turns and he was close to carpet to
carpet using the entire run and which is
safer for this skier
well if you make a small turn you're out
of the line of traffic
making large radius turns is fine but
you have to be aware of all your
surroundings and you have to be watching
to make sure that
you're not coming into traffic okay and
when you're let's play a little more and
will you tell us when to stop you're
seeing this on your own monitor stop
when you stop seeing things
a little bit further
right
just a
okay he's now below me right and so
that's when I turned away from him and
how many seconds is that on the just for
the record
I know okay
so
we're going to skis headed downhill when
you last looked
well on a short radius turn your skis
are going back and forth and and she was
making her turns very rhythmically she
was in a pattern you know and a rhythm I
mean and so
I mean she's her her body was facing
down the hill okay and have you known
her to be a reckless skier never or to
ski out of control no
okay and
what you stopped us here and I just want
to be clear was Mr Sanderson skis then
moving toward her that is correct now is
it possible Ms sent Mr Sanderson moved
ahead of her and then slowed down
I can't say for sure but the amount of
time that elapsed from the time that I
looked away to the time of the Collision
there was not much of speculation Lex
Foundation moved to strike
overruled
okay go ahead from the time that I
looked away until I heard the screen was
a very short period of time by the way
no one said that for instance Dr Mr
Sanderson pulled in front of her and
then came to a stop and then was hit
right I no no one has ever made that
claim all right and
um now we're going to jump ahead to when
they came to a stop
we're taking this off the screen
all right
um and how many seconds do we know is
this through
until it may turn till we go yeah I
gotta press play I think okay let's play
the remainder
uh so
there's Moses he's sort of stopped
um
they're the buckets in the top right
correct
yes I'm calling him buckets did you call
him snow making equipment well we call
them tubes tips typically they're big
round tubes that just fit over
everything because there's a standpipe
and electric sometimes an electrical
outlet sometimes it's a compressed air
pipe that comes up it's just protection
so people don't bump into it all right
and let's
uh let's just talk some more
are there risks associated with skiing
there certainly are
on the back side of every ski pass
you've ever seen are are those risks
identified
they are and what do they include
uh they say that skiing is
this is
we've already discussed this this is
goes beyond the scope of his testimony
and what's allowable uh if you'd like we
can approach
I think it's fine so I'm going to
overrule the objection go ahead okay
will the discussion about the inherent
risks of scheme
yeah I don't hear that question yet well
he just said well he asked him what was
printed on the back of a ticket
so overruled go ahead
comment on the back of every ski ticket
you've ever seen I think it's a talk
about liability of the ski area it does
state that there are risks involved that
there may be
patches without snow there may be rocks
or maybe trees
there is a possibility of collision with
stationary objects or other people
um
and so there is a risk when you ski and
uh so when Mr Sanderson bought his pass
he understood that the risk of a
collision with another skier that's
printed right right on this ticket
sustained
are you aware it references the risk of
collision with another skier as a as an
inherent risk of skiing
it is
overruled it is printed on the back of
the of the ticket yes
and the pass holder accepts full
responsibility for all risks associated
with the activities as we approach yes
all right let's talk about risks of
skiing so separate from the ski pass
okay uh I I do want you to just
reference what what do you understand
the risks of skiing to be
well you're dealing with a activity that
involves sliding on snow it covers
different conditions different weather
conditions different types of times of
the Season conditions can change
constantly
um
you can have a front that can move
through and it can go from a fairly nice
day to a super windy day with snow you
know blowing back forth so conditions
are changing constantly and
part of what we try to do as ski
instructors is to give people enough uh
skills that they can deal with all
conditions and there are times when you
have to go in I mean there's times where
it's just to
nasty outside and it's not comfortable
and you go in but we want to help people
be safe at all times
and uh
but sometimes even those skiers are
being careful collisions do occur
rejections
because her opinion evidence
sustained
comment on terrain terrain berries as
well terrain varies very much
you would never want to take a low level
low level skier
overruled
you would never want to take a low-level
skier on something that is over their
head where they would be frightened and
able to move and make mistakes
uh we try to keep our train that we ski
people on within their ability levels
and of course if you're trying to teach
it's much easier to teach if they're
comfortable on their terrain if it's if
they're only thinking about surviving
that train they it makes a very
unteachable time was is a skier expected
to ski within their own abilities they
are does that include physical abilities
such as ability to see and hear
I would say that covers it if you if you
have certain disabilities you want to
make sure that you compensated that by
the way that you were skiing the speed
you were skiing how you were looking
around
Etc from what you observed in your
investigation after the accident Do You
Believe Miss pal throw was skiing within
her ability at the time of the Collision
objection Foundation
because we're expert opinion it's just
so stained okay did you try to put
together whose fault this was
what happened was I objection pardon yes
or no
did you did you try to figure out what
happened yes and what did you do to do
that
I observed
how they were uh on the ground out an
expert opinion
overruled and from your honor we're
going to bring up his report right now
which has been pre-admitted but go ahead
what was your investigation the first
thing I did was Observe how they were on
the ground and what did you observe
that Mr Sanderson was his head was
uphill skis downhill
uh that Miss Paltrow
your honor is getting obstruction okay
come on up
one of the points uh
so is that over overruled
to me okay so uh we're going to bring up
that report what did You observe on the
issue of where the
people were at the when they came to a
club a stop so Sanderson versus okay
when they came to a stop they were very
close to skiers right the edge of the of
the Run
uh both were had their skis below them
both had their skis still on their boots
there was no releasing of skis
their heads were uphill their feet were
downhill and Miss Paltrow was on top of
Mr Sanderson and
uh what does that tell you the fact that
their skis were still on
it means that there was no heavy impact
which would knock them over like side to
side
there was no
basically it means that they went down
without any heavy impact on their on
their ski boots if someone were to come
and just kind of hit
and
literally project that person forward
objection expert opinion testimony so my
question is not complete just a minute
go ahead okay if someone were to come
and hit
a second skier and propel them airborne
so they're flying
would they have ended up where they were
when you saw them objection speculation
sustained okay how many how many
incidents like this have you uh
been present for
it would be impossible for me to say
because after 44 years of being a ski
instructor most of that full-time you
see a lot of different instances
I could not speculate on that so I
wouldn't cut I didn't I think I cut you
off because I I said what did you do to
try to figure out uh what happened so
okay you said I look at where they land
I look at go ahead then I look at the
positions of the body where they land
uh
it would be very difficult to get in
that position without somebody
hitting from behind okay I'm just strike
expert or just opinion evidence it's
sustained okay so
um what else do you look at other than
where they land the next thing I next
thing I observed was what they were
saying
and with um
of course Miss Paltrow was saying that
she had just been hit she never saw it
coming she was surprised Mr Sanderson
was made the statement that she just
appeared in front of him he was saying
he was sorry and that's basically the
conclusions that I came to
injection move to strike any conclusions
are opinions that like uh Foundation
that this witness is not uh
um able to not properly uh designated
these are speaking objections your honor
would you please approach the bench
let's go to your report so this is
called
d25a do you see this I do did you
prepare this that day yes and uh did you
engage in a cover-up to try to hide
gwyneth's Reckless skiing objection
relevance overruled
no I did not is that ridiculous and
offensive it's very much so
um part of what we're required to do is
if there is an incident
if there's an injury it's mandatory that
everything that we uh be written down in
a report and uh on instances where
there's uh a bump or or something like
that where there are no injuries it's up
to us to decide whether is prudent to
fill out the report and I decided it was
prudent that day okay and uh exact
location of the incident you wrote what
I wrote skiers right bandana slight
pitch before the flat on top okay is
that an accurate statement it is number
of students you said there was what
um there were six in group two
instructors okay now there's been some
testimony that brought her then
boyfriend now husband also had two kids
out with separate instructors is that
true that is correct and but they
weren't in that group of six that was
coming down bandana is that right that
is correct all right students ability
now it was Gwyneth the student here or
is well Moses was my student that I
skiing with but Gwyneth was the person
in the incident so I wrote her name on
the top there's some uh suggestion that
immediately before this incident somehow
Moses was going hey Mommy look at me
look at me did you observe that that did
not happen
and how do you know that because I was
next to him okay
um
so again any implication that she was
distracted because she was looking
across the hill to Moses you would
dispute objections
bleeding
reading
well
plaintiff has raised an issue and I want
to know if your thought on it
the thought is that the plaintiff is
asserted is that you uh
right before the incident
Moses was saying mommy mommy look at me
and your your thought on that objection
leading Lux Foundation Ms State's prior
testimony
overruled the jury will have to remember
the prior testimony
go ahead okay did that happen I never
saw that happen as we were skiing along
we were basically making our own turns
Miss Paltrow was skiing down making very
nice short radius turns
and we were separated by the width of
the of the bandana run I was skiing with
nine-year-old son
group was skiing down bandana to lunch
is that all true that is correct what
was the student doing at the time of the
incident
uh short turns down the fall line on
skiers right
by the way is at Gwyneth skied with you
all morning with Moses I think we took
one initial run together and then we
split up with uh the intention of being
at the top of of the Flagstaff Hill at a
certain time to go to a lunch all right
and had you and Moses already been on
some ski runs without Gwyneth yes
and how many about
probably in that time span about four or
five
short turns down fall line is that what
that says fall line yes what does that
mean again the thaw line is if you were
to take a round object like a ball set
it down it's the path that it would fall
fall down the hill so it's basically the
most correct downhill line on skiers
right so the references where on the Run
correct Spears right would be as you're
facing down the hill would be here
skiers left of course over here next
portion
Chief complaint would you read your
answer
Mill skier took her out from behind I
didn't see it but heard her scream as
she went down I skied directly to her
the man was behind her
both were in discomfort during lunch she
talked to being stiff and sore all right
let's just talk about that
male skier took her out from behind why
did you say that
because of the positioning of their
bodies on the ground but also
he was I clearly observed him as the
uphill skier
now you can't
right on the skier responsibility code
it says that the uphill skier has the
responsibility to avoid the downhill
skier because as we're skiing our vision
cannot see behind us and that's the
reason for the responsibility code
and since I observed him moving very
rapidly down the hill and only missed a
few moments before the contact I can
clearly say that he was the uphill skier
did you determine one of them violated
the skier responsibility code
that would be my observation
Way Beyond the scope of this Witnesses
overruled and who who who did you
believe violated the responsibility code
and who complied with it I would say
that the episode
okay what did you find at the time with
regard to the skier responsibility code
sustained okay
may I consult with my counsel just one
sec
all right next statement here
first of all you need to read a true
statement is what you said were you
speaking the truth when you prepared
this report
okay uh where were you in relationship
to the student at the time of the
incident I was above the student okay
um
did you witness the incident I had I
said no because I did not see the impact
if not how did you become aware of the
incident I saw the immediate aftermath
whiskey Patrol called or first aid
visited you you marked what I marked no
because we did not call patrol because
Patrol came along very soon after that
and to the right there what did you
write name of patroller
um I did not catch the name I wish that
I had but uh
once again if there had been comments of
oh I'm I'm hurt something's wrong things
like that things would have changed very
quickly
but what happened was I was in the
process of helping Mr Sanderson get his
skis back on
um I I had my skis off and both he and
Mr Ramon were there together
the patrollers came by and one of them
came up to us and said asked if they
needed any assistance
this is what I see he is explaining a
story this is exactly what I observed I
guess for limited purpose not
necessarily as to the truth of what this
person said but as to why he acted the
way he did so it's limited purpose
evidence okay okay keep going okay so
controller set so the patroller asks if
they needed assistance
Mr Sanderson and Mr Ramon spoke to each
other I was just kneeling on the snow I
was I did not hear what they said but
they turned to the patroller and said no
we're fine something to that effect and
so the two patrollers continued down the
hill and that's the student return to
skiing that's Miss pal throw but comment
did did you see Mr Sanderson then ski
away
I was the last one to put on my ski so
they Mr Sanderson Mr Ramon were already
in their skis
I was the very last one to leave
and so I I I can't recall exactly how
they skied off but we basically either
skied off together at the same time or
they left slightly ahead of me
okay we're going to look at the end of
this report and move on here
additional information you wrote Carrie
Oaks correct right she was the other
instructor that was there additional
comments first thing male skier
ski status
should be mail skier was that she
appeared right in front of him
thus admitting that he was the uphill
skier she never saw him because he came
in from behind it was that you're
finding on that day
that was my finding yes so there's I
think a comment that because she was
tipping you for your service
that you falsified your report is that
true that is ridiculous uh it says this
was reviewed by Liz Wright is that your
supervisor or what she is a supervisor
um not my direct supervisor but a
supervisor in the ski school yes and
that's your signature bottom right it is
and so same day of the event did you try
to accurately represent everything I did
um in my mind at that point I thought
that all issues had been resolved I
never expected it to
um come to this type of a situation and
so I was simply writing down briefly
what happened if I had realized
that this would come to this type of a
situation I would have written much more
and much more in detail
did I hear you say that you never
observed the Mr Sanderson unconscious oh
absolutely not and were you there within
seconds
probably within
oh 10 to 15 seconds I the first thing
that I did was I turned to miss Oaks and
said you take Moses I'm going to go over
and help out or something to that and
then it was kind of a flat Traverse and
so I simply skied across and I was there
within maybe 10 seconds Mr Sanderson
said you've gotten his face and yelled
at him I did not
the tone of my voice would be very
similar to what it is right now
I think they're about to get up and
suggest that you were sort of in
gwyneth's agent in
uh making a cover-up
Direction
do you legal opinion I'm gonna have them
comment on it once you leave it for
redirect okay
that is my cue to sit down okay thank
you for your time certainly thank you Mr
Owens
Buehler
or that third animation went from zero
to eight and then from 16 to 22.
foreign
Mr Christensen do you recall your
deposition of October 27 2020. yes I do
in your deposition
you mentioned that uh
um Terry Sanderson he was underneath her
and she was talking about discomfort
she was shocked she was somewhat hurt
is that correct
she was in discomfort that is true well
she heard
so there's a difference between being
hurt and injured
and so anytime that you have some type
of instinct you're going to be hurt to
some degree but that doesn't mean that
you're injured
to find that Miss Carrie Oaks
was instructed by you to take the kids
down the left side correct
I didn't tell her I just tell her to
take Moses I didn't tell her where to go
okay
um
Miss Oak said she went over to the crash
scene
and was assisting you with the two uh
people in the crash no she at one point
she had the kids follow her and they
went down the hill and they came by us a
little bit but she did not assist no did
she stop by you
no
did she uh
also say that one of the kids said Mommy
watch us ski
that would have happened at the very top
of the hill not well not at the time of
the instant yeah but before just before
not no it didn't happen while it was
just before the incident I would say
within 10 seconds no
well how long would it take to go from
when you say the top of the hill do you
mean when you get off the chairlift yeah
as you get off the chair lift you have
to push yourself a little bit at the top
of the bandana run and it would have
been in that area
so it would have been you know a minute
or so ahead
so the the viewpoint
of those animations those demonstrative
you know like a cartoon it was uh would
would was that where Miss Oaks would
have heard one of the children say mommy
watch us ski
it would have been before we started to
get to that point well how do you know
that you testified that didn't happen
what I'm saying is it didn't happen
during that time
okay so you you do you agree then that
one of the children said Mommy watch us
ski
I cannot speak to that all I know is it
didn't happen while we were skiing down
the hill
could it I mean it could have happened
with Miss Oak she could have heard it
maybe she did Miss Paltrow I mean why
would the kids say that if but for they
wanted her their mother to hear them and
watch them ski
at the time of the incident
there was nothing said we were busy
making our own turns
but just before
the incident there was some seconds that
elapsed maybe 10 15. that's when
Miss Paltrow would have heard one of her
children say mommy watch us ski
I never observed hearing that
okay
you never saw the ski crash right I
didn't see the impact no I did not
you said uh
she screamed before the crash right
well I heard her scream which would
possibly be when the contact was made
could the screen that occurred before
the contact no
you have no basis of knowing that
because you didn't see it
Miss Paltrow doesn't go down the hill
screaming
there would be no reason for her to
scream just to scream that's your
speculation because you didn't see it
right I did not see the point of impact
no
you've heard of photographic memory
right
I've heard of identity memory yes
I don't know if this is a word but it
sounds like you have a videographic
memory you've got a
view of everything in front of you and
to the side and behind and the last for
several minutes
Mr Beeler Quinn an incident like this
occurs is very much in your mind and you
remember the things very clearly
now this was about your third
time instructing for Miss Paltrow's
family on her third vacation for her
isn't that true that is correct
and
isn't it true that you got so close to
the family
maybe not close friends but close enough
that you sent Moses her son some
handmade pottery that you've made I
didn't send them I gave them to him on
their last day
on this trip
not on this trip I'm not sure to be
honest with you the trip before I think
two trips I gave him some things
did you give out candy to the kids no
did you ever tell
Greg Ramon
your buddy just took out Gwyneth Paltrow
I don't recall that
do you recall telling Ms Paltrow's name
to Terry Sanderson or
I don't recall it I it may have come up
but I don't recall
with Miss Paltrow skiing away in her
group skiing away
you were the last one at the crash site
with Terry Sanderson and Craig Ramon
right I did stay with them until they
were up and on their skis that is
correct
they being Miss Paltrow know that
they've been Mr Sanderson Mr Ramon well
Mr Ramon wasn't on the phone he didn't
take off his keys or he wasn't on the
ground no he he never took off his skis
that I uh but Mr Sanderson had his skis
off because I took him off and so
um
I was helping him put his skis back on
and that that was what was going on when
the patrol came by
you never got the name of the patrol
true that is true once again
did you uh
report to this to the ski patrol at any
time
if people say they are not hurt I know
we I just wanted to no I did not report
it because once again we heard your
Patrol came and he refused
interrupting the witness
okay well taken council did you finish
your response uh my response is that
they were offered help from Patrol and
they refused
other Witnesses say that the body
positions that Miss Paltrow and you say
were she's on top of Terry Sanderson
they testified that the positions were
different than that do you know that
it doesn't matter what they say I can
only tell you what I saw and what I
observed
you've talked about the importance of
filling out a incident report accurately
right yes
you mentioned that Miss Paltrow said she
was or indicated or looked like she was
sore
may have been hurt or Was Heard
according to your deposition right
you know that's what she told me during
lunch yes
okay
and you filled out your report later
at the end of the day yes
but
in your report you never got the names
of
Terry Sanderson right I did not you
never got the name of the only
eyewitness we know of Craig Ramon right
I did not because once again
when people say I'm fine I'm sorry
and when I asked them if they're if
they're hurt they say no
you know um
they went their way we went our way
do you know Gwyneth Paltrow says she got
up by herself
I also I can say is I helped everybody
get their skis off and she may have gone
up by herself
um I may have helped her with an arm
said her skis weren't off
you know that and they never came off
well no they never came off during the
the instant I removed them so that they
could get untangled
backing up
right after you heard the screen
you didn't see the Collision
you you
skied over
and you yelled at Terry Sanderson
what did you do what did you do true
that is not true
you don't yell at all in your life
I did not yell first of all I was trying
to observe what was happening and I took
off my skis I came around to try to
untangle them I did not yell at Mr
Sanderson
do you ever teach group lessons I do I
do sometimes the students spread out
at Deer Valley uh private rotation
instructors teach Max Force which means
there's no more than four people in your
group
so I do teach those
as far as spreading out you try to keep
your group as close together as possible
but there are tasks that where they may
go down one at a time and things like
that
well if a student goes far away don't
you yell at that student to come get
back in line don't you have to holler at
them I don't yell I don't have they hear
you then
we ski down to them well then the other
students go another Direction
you never use it raise your voice at
Deer Valley is that your policy
if I raise my voice I lose my voice very
quickly I can't yell
um you know as far as talking to
students
you could you try to maintain a class
situation where we will stop at certain
places and we'll gather together we try
to always gather at the edge of the run
so we're out of the line of traffic
but no I don't go around yelling all
over the resort
I didn't say that I just said
do you ever yell once to add a student
who might be too far away from your
group and you want them to come back
no they can't come back if they're below
you you have to go to them they're not
going to come up the hill
you can't see
hey come back over here bill
oh I might if they're just across the
run I will say things like that but I'm
not yelling
you're Whispering or no I'm talking in
the normal voice
but if
you know if there's a lift Machinery
there's noise or something you never
raise your voice at all while you're ski
instructing
this is getting a little silly don't you
think
I don't know you're the one that says
you never yell while you're ski
instructing I find that hard to believe
so you didn't see the crash but you saw
injury and soreness
and you didn't get the
plaintiff's name
even though Miss Paltrow may have been
hurt
doesn't that seem like a violation of
what you're supposed to do as a ski
instructor at Deer Valley
what I was relying on was the comments
of both parties
and both parties said that they were
okay
as far as Mr Sanderson being injured he
had a wonderful opportunity to tell
Patrol I am hurt I need help and but
instead he refused help and had Patrol
continue on their way
those are the with when things like that
happen I made the decision that he was
okay and so once I had his skis on I put
my skis on and I left
you know within maybe three minutes of
you leaving this crash scene
Mr Sanderson was talking to us he
patroller who actually wrote a report he
said he had sore ribs and disorientation
objection
overruled asking if the witness knew
that may have happened then but he did
not report that to me and that was after
I had asked him and once again the troll
had asked him
the mystery Patrol that you don't know
the name of right
I do not know the name but they know who
it is from the log
basically they have a log where they
write down when they go out to make a
ski around so
they do know who that individual is but
once again
if you're a ski patroller
and you come up on an uh someone and you
say do you need help
and they say they do not
and you ski on
three or four years later it's very
unlikely that they will remember that
incident I wouldn't correct you just
said that the uh
the incident that you report which is
Terry Sanderson waved off the ski Patrol
is in us in a log
ski patroller's log no their rotation of
who who would be going down would be in
the log
okay but there's no uh there's no report
of this in the ski patroller's lock that
you just reported is in there that's
because they stopped and he did not ask
for assistance and so there's no reason
that they would walk go down and ride in
a log stopped and talked to this person
they didn't need help
so you're saying then your testimony
from about one minute ago is incorrected
it's in the there's should be a
a log report of Terry Sanderson waving
off no that's not what I said that's
what I thought you said that may be what
you thought I said what I said was that
when skier Escape throw goes out and
takes a run
and just observes things they put in a
log that when they leave and make that
run
so
the they do know who was on the hill at
that time
so are you speculating about this
the skiers log that it was going to show
this this um you know this you can talk
to Steve Graf when he
um testifies because he's the one that
told us that they pretty well know who
it is
but once again
if somebody if somebody stops and talks
to somebody for just a few moments and
then skeeze off
they're not going to remember that four
or five years later because it was such
a minor instant they stop and talk to
people constantly and unless there's an
incident where they have to respond it's
not going to be something that they keep
in their memory
right but the
four broken ribs severely broken ribs my
client Terry Sanderson had
they're the kind of
make it hard to breathe let alone talk
well
and you're speculating that he was not
injured
correct no I'm not speculating I'm
saying that he never said he was injured
there's a difference
because he couldn't speak no he was
speaking
he's I I have no knowledge of that
because I don't know the man
I don't know how he speaks normally
just give me a moment
excuse me
you say if
if kind of
applies to me that you're speculating or
it's not
necessarily true if
the patrol log had information about who
was skiing down at the time of this
crash
we don't have that information
remember these
okay
sustained sustained was Brad falchuk at
the scene of the crash
he was slightly downhill
I don't know 20 to 30 yards possibly
that's slightly 20 to 30 yards
he was ahead of us
did you say I mean is that your
testimony 20 or 30 yards approximately
I'm I'd be speculating at this point but
I know that he was ahead of us
well you knew that Craig Ramon was
maybe 60 80 yards maybe out of the
picture I didn't say that I said that he
was
time wise it took him about 45 seconds
to get to us I never said anything about
distance what if Greg Ramon was right
behind you and you could you don't have
eyes behind your head do you
I do know that
when I responded and came over I took
off my skis I was helping both parties I
was over the edge just slightly on
skiers right I could see the whole uh
ski area uh ski run in front of me
Mr Ramon didn't show up
for approximately 45 seconds
so all I am saying is that he was a took
him longer to come down the run I have
no idea how far up the hill he was but
he was not close enough to be right on
the scene
so the animation where it depicts Mr
Ramon way up the hill is based on not
your testimony
I never saw Mr Ramon on the animation
did I I don't are you looking to counsel
to answer for you I don't I don't
remember seeing Mr Ramon on the
animation so that part of the animation
is fiction
it's not supported by your opinion
I do not know where Mr Ramon was no
um that's all for right now unless
if Brad falchuk said he was first on the
scene is that true
overruled okay
I would say that I was the first one on
the scene
that's all for right now thank you
thank you Mr Bueller
Mr Owens
to better copy of the prior defense 110
and I'd like to add
from this yes yes okay as long as the
other side has seen it
oh you're giving are these my copies
okay
sure yes
yes
take a look at that I I had a terrible
copy of this before
but defense 110
uh
our texts between you and Gwyneth you
recognize them
yes they're on my phone they're better
they're better quality on your phone
than
my photographing gwyneth's phone
are these true and accurate documents
yes they are and so they're 110 A and B
and let's just go through them really
quick Friday February 26th that's the
day of the event true
um the accident yes we went yes and are
you uh the dark color on the right or
the lighter color on the left no I'm the
one that's in dark color
we went down bandana why are you saying
that to Gwyneth
okay
um
yes we went down bandana okay cool we
should take North Side Up you said yes
we are going to north side again feel
free to do your own thing you wrote what
we are we are Ruby lived okay that's at
10 36. we have new skis this is 205u
right we have new skis
we've gone down Ontario and we're back
to smiles she wrote yay
and then 229 Moses wants to know if you
are skiing still skiing and where you
wrote that to my client yes and she
wrote and a little further down James
I came in that guy sort of hurt me
I'm going to
get a massage at three Gigi is here if
he wants to come in was that a true and
accurate statement yes yes
by the way so separate from this carry
Oaks
um
uh
she has some memories are would you
defer to her on what she remembers
um I know that she could testify about
Mr sanderson's terms because we both
observed him making
fast
white turns down the hill and Brad
falchuk has some memories and he's gonna
uh would you defer to his memories I
don't really know Brad at all so and
I've never talked to him really so I
can't say anything to that yeah I'm just
saying um but like were you focused on
what Carrie was doing and what Brad
falchuk was doing or were you focused on
the two people who had a collision I was
actually focused on Moses but part of
focusing on Moses is being aware of
everything around me
those are all my questions thank you
thank you Mr Owens
are we done with this one
a little bit sure let's take a short
break now
you are right now but same instruction
as before you're welcome to step down
for our witness who's about to come can
we just get a sense for how many minutes
left
so I had a very narrow redirect but uh
proceed we will
Mr Christensen you can come on up jury's
on their way in
could you
verify that they are
honor I'm sorry no more questions for
uh okay
uh you can he doesn't want to stay up
there did you have any redirect uh no I
mean there'd be a small possibility we'd
call them later in the week if something
new comes up okay I'll just excuse you
in front of the jury then okay
next witness in the courtroom
yeah go ahead
right
thank you
so Mr Christensen there's there are no
more questions for you from the lawyer
so your excuse for today but you may be
called back thank you thank you
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God thank you
good afternoon yes
and maybe once you get up to the
microphone if you could State your full
name and spell it thank you
Whitney Smith
w-h-i-t-n-e-y s-m-i-t-h
Whitney thank you for being here and
um
we will try to get through you quickly
we're at the end of the day and we want
to uh
make sure that um
we're respectful of your time here we
again appreciate you coming
um
let's begin by asking you where you're
from
I'm from Michigan
and
have you ever met Gwyneth Paltrow no
no have you ever met Terry Sanderson
yeah how did you meet him I met him at
Deer Valley I believe it was in 2016.
and what was the nature of that
interaction
um I responded to an incident on the
bandana run where he was injured
and do you have memories of that day and
those events I do okay and as I
understand you also created a report
about that yes okay and we'll look at
that report but you were in uh I think
the capacity of a ski patrol person when
you came upon him or when you were
called to the scene is that correct
correct and
um can you give the jury just a sense of
your experience and training that got
you to that point that you could be a
ski patrol person sure
um I at that point I had my EMT basic
which is our level
and I've been I think that was my second
year patrolling so we had some medical
training and we set up ropes pads
boundaries everything around the
mountain and respond to incidents
do you have any EMT training I do yes
I'm an emergency medical technician okay
and can you give the jury just a sense
of what that means sure um it's sort of
basic first aid that we're able to
render there on the slopes deal with any
kind of life threats and then our main
deal with skate Patrol is stabilize the
patient and remove them from a cold
environment down to somewhere where we
can reassess okay and did you have that
training at the time of the accident I
did okay how many years had you been in
EMT before then do you recall I think it
was about two years at that point
so you had seen other accidents like
that or you had come upon other accents
with that EMT training to respond I had
responded to several more than several
incidents at that point okay do you have
any rough estimate as to how many uh no
I don't sorry but that's fine
um
let's let's go with your memories first
then we'll go to your report real
briefly what what do you recall caused
you to go to that scene where Mr
Sanderson had called you
I don't have a specific recollection of
the radio call but I know that Flagstaff
Mountain which was where bandana is was
called and notified that there was a
potentially an incident on bandana
I was sent to respond to that
and what was your understanding at the
time of what the incident was that
needed a response
um I wasn't sure at that point what it
was it just came in as um probably we
call it a possible 1050 a possible
incident in the location got it and then
what do you remember seeing when you got
to that point
when I came up I saw Mr Sanderson
standing on the side of the run you know
there's a mountain house present who I
believe was the one made the radio call
and a friend was there
and then I skied up and began talking
with them okay and what's your role what
are the things that you typically do
when you respond to an incident like
this sure so as as I come into a scene
I'm already doing a bit of a scene size
up
um sometimes there's Clues right if
there had been like skis up the run and
someone's way down and you can tell
something happened so a size up to maybe
get
a feel for what's going on and then I go
in and I usually introduce myself ask
them their name
um and just sort of hey what's happened
what's going on today and then from
there do you have any pain or anything
like that and was there it was your
understanding that there had been a
collision
um not offhand but once I had gotten
there when I asked what had happened
they said there was a collision and who
reported that to you uh Mr Sanderson and
what did he tell you I don't recall
specifically I think when I asked like
hey what happened they just said there
was a collision up higher and then they
had skied down and decided that they
couldn't keep skiing down and needed
assistance got it so you got to this a
site that was different from the
Collision side yes okay and
um Do You Remember
uh hearing anything from Mr Ramon the
friend that was there
um while I was doing my assessment I
don't remember specific words but I know
that he had mentioned a couple of times
that there was a collision beforehand
and who may have been involved did he
ever tell you that he had witnessed the
Collision no he was mostly talking to Mr
Sanderson and I was kind of overhearing
while I was assessing okay
and
um
what was your assessment in terms of the
physical potential for physical injury
um so as I was talking with him I was
um asking him if he had pain I do recall
he was talking about some right-sided
rib pains who went through a major
breathing and whatnot was okay and then
he said he was able to answer all my
questions appropriately but did seem a
bit rattled
okay do you remember him complaining
about anything related to his brain or
his head I don't recall
Did You observe him to have any
cognitive disability or limitations for
my assessment he was alert and oriented
by four which is part of our assessment
there which means he's he's four out of
four okay and explain that to the jury
that 4x4 idea yeah
um so it's to see if you're oriented um
two-person Place time and event so I'll
ask you know do they know who they are
do they know what day it is
um
events do they know what happened and
then um
and I usually give them sort of a
general like politics question like
who's the president if they can answer
that then they're usually
got it so you're just trying to test
that they're cognitively aware and able
to speak to you communicate with you yes
and you do that every time as a matter
of course just anytime you are on a
scene and obsessing a person yeah you
can typically just kind of throw those
in for conversation and get a feel of
how someone is cognating so you feel
confident that you did that I did do
that
um
did you do anything to assess the rib
pain at that point
um I don't recall specifically doing
that I can tell you how I would
do that so I can tell with you with
confidence if that's what I wrote in my
report that is what I did
okay um
and speaking of the report what's the
reason that you actually wrote out a
report in this case when we go on an
incident with someone who has an injury
we just fill out paperwork for
everyone's liability and future needs
okay just trying to get down what the
facts that were reported to you and that
you observed sure
um
okay so you assessed Mr Sanderson on the
hill
and at that point did he know who hit
him
um no he never said who hit him he just
was like yes I was in a collision did he
know what had happened he aside from
saying um I believe according to my
paperwork he said he was hit from behind
so that was what he told me in a
collision but beyond that he didn't have
much in the way of specifics okay
um and then what about uh Mr Ramon did
he report to you any details about what
he had seen
he mentioned a couple times that the
skier involved had been miss Paltrow but
beyond that there were no specifics of
like how it happened and do you know how
he knew it was Miss Paltrow
um I do not
I hazarded a guess that he had seen but
I don't know for sure was it a little
surprising that a name that you knew
like a celebrity name had come up sure
it wasn't what I expected for the day
right right and
um was Mr Ramon believable to you
um he wasn't I wasn't talking a whole
ton directly to him because I was busy I
wanted to assess my patient and make
sure that he was in a good in a good way
and didn't need anything super immediate
so I do recall when
um it had been brought up that there was
a collision that I had asked if the
other party was okay because I wanted to
make sure there wasn't another injured
person floating around somewhere I see
um
but you didn't have your own
conversation with Mr Ramon about what he
had seen no
no and what about did you hear anything
about someone being unconscious with Mr
Sanderson being unconscious for a few
minutes no I didn't get that reported
that would have to the seriousness of
that call for me really fast yeah so
that's my next question if you had heard
Mr Sanderson was unconscious for two
minutes or a long time
um what would you have done
um that would have been if if you're
reporting a loss of consciousness
typically you get to leave the resort in
an ambulance that's kind of where that
goes even if you're mentating correctly
for me there if I hear you were out cold
on the snow for two minutes I'm going to
call an ambulance and let you refuse
them directly and and what about loss of
consciousness for a shorter period of
time than that even five seconds sure
any any loss of consciousness if someone
said hey this person was out I'm gonna
start looking at that okay and you feel
confident that you did not hear about
anything like that I don't recall ever
hearing that now
um
and I think I asked you this but just to
make sure did Mr Ramon tell you how he
believed that what led him to believe
that Mrs Powter had been the other
person in the Collision I know aside
from saying the name he didn't
okay so then once you've
done that assessment have we covered
that assessment I should ask that on the
hill
I'm sorry could you repeat the question
yeah have we covered what you did in
that assessment will you remember in
that assessment on the hill
um yes I mean there's a bit more to it
probably please I don't want to cut you
off sure there's uh it's a head to toe
right it's not just if you tell me your
ribs hurt I'm absolutely gonna look at
that but they can distract from other
things so it's a it's a head to toe
assessment to make sure that there's
nothing sneaky happening elsewhere
um and then I would have like palpated
the ribs have him breathe in make sure
that's all going properly got it okay
and uh what were your findings after
that head to toe assessment the majority
was that rib pain
um he wasn't having trouble breathing so
I was comfortable with that
um but he definitely had something going
on in that vicinity okay
got it
then as I understand it I think Mr
Anderson has spoken to this that he was
taken on a toboggan is that right
correct yeah I um packaged him in the
sled and took him down to our first
state area okay and what happened after
that um we would have gone into first
aid and
um I think sort of reassess once we're
in a place where okay pull your jacket
off blow your helmet off does anything
else hurt now that it's been a few
minutes
um and then from there I do recall I
spent a fair amount of time waiting for
his friend to bring the car around so we
we chatted for a bit and when you say a
bit you know I I asked him in how long
that actually started around two hours
how long was the assessment on the hill
I was probably 10 minutes that's a rough
estimate but 10 to 15 before we were
packaged and moving so you spent a lot
more time with him in the first date
Clinic yeah
sorry I did yes yes it's okay and um and
is that typical that you would stay with
a patient for two hours
it's um a bit abnormal we do try and get
back up into rotation but also um your
balance customer service says that we
stay with the patient Until the End make
sure you know A to B they're on their
way and are in a good spot and it's also
just good medical care to not
see you bye right right that makes sense
and was there any reason aside from
waiting for this car that you needed to
stay with him for two hours I wanted to
keep assessing and make sure that he
didn't Trend uh downward in any of his
symptoms which he did not so that was
the main reason was just to make sure he
got on his way
okay so was there any indication early
in the first aid visit the reassessment
down at the bottom of the hill that he
would need two hours of care from you no
okay and why do you say that
um his he wasn't you know trending
downward his his symptoms were staying
the same with his root pain
um and sort of that rattled kind of
feeling that I'd noted on the hill
seemed to be dissipating we were able to
converse pretty well okay and
um
was there any time during all of that
afternoon that you spent with Mr
Sanderson that you
uh saw evidence of a head injury or a
brain injury
no I as time went on I said this guy is
ano4 so I felt comfortable releasing in
private vehicle and was that ano for is
that what you just said yes okay and
again that means that he was alert to
those four different categories earlier
correct and I think he earlier told the
jury that you gave him some things to
remember yes yeah there's a handful of
sort of head assessments you can do and
that's one of them I'll usually give
somebody three words and then sort of
periodically throughout the same time
I'll ask him to repeat that for me right
and was one of them your horse's name
um no that's not usually one I use I use
blue snow 24 without fail the whole time
epidurals
okay and um
let's see so
uh you were doing various tests to make
sure that he was
fully alert and his cognitive facilities
were intact is that correct correct and
you found no concern he was he was yeah
he was not trending downward he was
solid but did you encourage him to go
get further care at all I did yeah and
what was that for he had the rib pain
and I told him if any other concerns
came up then you should talk to whoever
sees you at the clinic
okay got it so let's go to your report
um well actually let's finish the day so
you you finished with him once he got a
ride and he knew that he was okay that
he had someone to take him uh I what did
you do after that
um I would have rotated back to the top
I don't have a specific memory of that
but I would have rotated back to the top
of a mountain and checked in okay got it
and then uh uh did you talk to anybody
else during the day after you had been
with Mr Sanderson about what had
happened sure when I came in for the
evening
um our he was then our Patrol director
Steve Graf I just sort of mentioned like
oh hey it's kind of a
interesting sidebar somebody said they
saw Ms Paltrow on the slopes today may
have had something to do with my
incident and it was sort of just a
three-minute conversation and then
what was did uh was there any discussion
about the injuries or was it just the
fact that it was Miss Paltrow involved
just just the fact that
and you obviously were not there I think
it's you've made it clear you weren't
there at the actual collision and you
didn't see what happened correct correct
and you never saw Miss Paltrow that day
I did not you didn't talk to her no
okay I'm gonna
uh put your report on the screen here
um it will also come up on that screen
okay uh I believe it has already been
published to the jury this is defense 24
a
is that correct yes and it's also a
plaintiff's exhibit one okay thank you
Okay so
let's see this is
I'm using a different chord here up up
here that I haven't been using back at
my table and it's not working let's
re-plug it
sorry for that let's wait I had been
working
okay I think let's go back to we know
that this this one works
pull it up here
and it should be good
okay there we go sorry for that wait
thank you for your patience okay so is
this your report it is and
when did you create it
um the date on it is the 26th of
February 2016. so that's that's when I
would have done it okay do you remember
what time in the day
I don't specifically recall but it does
say 12 p.m on there okay got it and uh
I'm just gonna go through
a few parts of it here so if we pull up
the
the first part oh I'm actually I
apologize
I'm on um
yeah
should I redact that first part
I apologize
I had it redacted on here and it just
delete
okay
so
my apologies okay
so uh I just want to point out a couple
things so here on the right side there's
a weight and a height you see that yes
and do you just get that from a report
from the patient I typically just ask
yes okay
and then here it says collision and you
say yes
correct yes and then here it says width
and it says unknown other party not
present
what did why did you write that because
the Mr Sanderson wasn't sure about who
the person involved of the Collision was
and they weren't there for me to find
and then if we go
to
this next section here
there's
a mention of num a similar injury or
illness and it says yes
yes you see that and then this is year
2010 do you recall what that was
regarding I don't recall the specific
um mention of what happened in 2010 but
that relates directly to what I checked
lower down in the form as the injury so
it would have been for the ribs okay got
it
yeah let's go to that so down here where
you talk about the injury it's a section
that's called possible injury correct
here on the side yes and you checked
fracture I see there's a x there correct
yes and strain and sprain
what were those connected to to the ribs
yes we don't we do not diagnose so
that's why it's possible got it and then
there's also a note of uh or a box uh
relating to concussion and then head
over here those are not checked correct
correct
and uh would you have checked those if
you were concerned about possible
concussion I would have and then a head
injury as well correct and then this
section over here says other and then if
I'm reading your handwriting correctly
it says ribs yes okay got it
uh and then it says right over here is
that related to the ribs the right side
yes okay so uh this document is a an
accurate representation of the injuries
that you thought he possibly sustained
on that on that correct okay
and this also
mentions that first aid was rendered
both at injury site you had an
assessment correct yes and then also in
the aid area you reassess correct and
you've already explained those two
assessments right yes okay
there's one part that I
um
redacted that I want to pull up so give
me a second
um
okay so this section here
says corrective lenses required and it
says yes do you see that oh whoops it's
gone sorry yeah I'm sorry go ahead
corrective lenses required yes yes and
then it says Warn and you check no
correct correct and why would you have
done that
um if someone I'll ask them the
corrective lenses question if they do
need them if they tell me yes and I
don't visibly see glasses I'll ask if
they have contacts in and if they tell
me no then I'll check now okay got it
the second page of your report is
defend its exhibit 24b and I think we've
already published this correct no
objections I know we have between us
exhibit one which is the exact same
document similar right okay thanks and
then uh here I just wanted to point out
there's various
places where you could kind of describe
a little more detail correct yes and
here's a section where you get a talk
about what you did and it says
assessment do you see that yes and then
mild disorientation what did you mean by
that so I put assessment and then those
would be my findings on that assessment
his mild disorientation
when I was there was the um the lack of
specificity for what had happened during
the Collision he was able to tell me
that there's a collision and not much
beyond that or who was involved and then
the rip pain that we found okay so that
mild disorientation and when you wrote
it you didn't mean that to indicate any
cognitive problems or concern for
concussion anything like that I think it
did originally Spike my concern for a
head injury because he wasn't able to
tell me how he felt but then as time
went on I became less concerned about
that as I noted later right and are you
referring to the reassessment that says
dis orientation lesson yes got it okay
um I also know on this page that uh
there's a section down here that says
witness and there's you know contact
information and identifying identifying
information you could have put here but
you didn't put anything is that correct
correct and why didn't you put anything
no one seemed to be a direct witness to
what happened
okay if Mr Ramon had told you I saw this
and here's what happened you would have
put his name here yes okay
and at the bottom you can't see it that
well with what I called out but is that
your signature at the bottom yes whoops
so sorry about that
if you go here right at the bottom it
says I carefully read the above
statement and it is true and accurate
yeah and then that's your signature
signature correct okay you stand by that
signature I do okay
okay
um let's go back to 24a real quickly
because there's one part I want to hit
uh that I missed uh actually I need more
than that there's this section that says
injured description of incident and it
says was hit from behind correct correct
and
am I reading this correctly that this
was Mr Sanderson who Mr sanderson's
description because he was the injured
yes yeah typically I I asked the injured
party what happened and then I'll write
down exactly what they tell me got it
okay
um
there's also an addendum to your report
right there is and
can you tell the jury why you made an
addendum to your report sure
um our and I forget who exactly made the
request but it was just requested that I
fill out an extra form with anything
else I might have remembered okay and
this is defendants exhibit 25b and I
think it has been published no objection
correct no objection it's also part of
plaintiff's exhibit one great
okay so is this the additional comments
that you made it is okay and uh there's
a date down at the bottom I know that's
318 2016 which is obviously after the
accident correct correct and so
um again why did you do this a few weeks
later sure to my knowledge
um it had come to note that maybe Miss
Paltrow had been present on the mountain
and with all the
um
different I guess different information
coming to the office I wasn't privileged
to that um they thought that maybe they
would want some more information for
that so they asked me to write it down
okay so was there was there a question
in your mind initially about whether
Miss Paltrow actually was involved
no it wasn't something I was really
thinking about okay so you weren't sure
whether what Mr Ramon said it was true
yes I was just focused on patient care
at that point okay
and if we go to the actual uh
comments here let's do your first
paragraph
do you mind reading it for us sure I
recall that upon arriving on scene on
bandana at the bridge I found the
patient Terry standing on the right side
of the run in his skis the Mountain
House set at Radio Patrol was above
doing traffic control a friend of
Terry's was also present a large man
Blue Jacket black pants dark hair hereby
referred to as large male friend Terry
said that he was uncertain what had
happened
lmf told Terry that a woman had struck
him from behind knocking him down omf
stated he had believed that the woman
had been Gwyneth Paltrow
okay so there's this note I think you've
already described this but I want to
make sure I understand Terry said that
he was uncertain what had happened he he
actually told you that correct okay and
then
lmf who uh you understand is Craig Ramon
is that right yes and told Terry that a
woman had struck him from behind
knocking him down so that was something
you heard Ramon tell Terry yes tell you
that
let's go to the next
section here
do you mind reading it for us
I asked if anyone had spoken to the
woman
can I call him Craig and this is that
all right sure I mean you know who it is
Craig said he had asked her if she was
all right he said she had told him she
was fine in skeedaway during assessment
transport and time in first aid Craig
continued to say that the woman involved
in the Collision was Gwyneth Paltrow so
you remember that he he kept bringing up
this point of Miss Paltrow's involvement
I do and you don't know how he knew it
was her no I don't okay
and then I think the last section which
I guess is a couple paragraphs sorry I
get cut that off
um
so at Empire first aid we were met by
three others from Terry skinger do you
remember that I do and who were those
um according to this it was a blonde
woman a man and Debbie okay
um I don't specifically recall it I do
know they came in at first aid to like
check on their friend but that's the
extent of my recollection there okay did
they stay with Terry the whole time he
was there
um no after and I don't know how long um
everybody went back out skiing and one
went to go get the car okay and left
Terry with you alone correct okay
uh and then there's another sentence
here it seems like the similar things
you've said before I recall lmf or Craig
reiterating to the group his
identification of the woman to have been
Gwyneth Paltrow
do you see that I do and when you write
his identification of the woman does
that mean that it was your understanding
that he personally identified the person
as Miss Paltrow
that was yes I guess I probably made the
assumption that it was a sight thing and
that's what he had come up with
and we left to retrieve the car came
back and picked him up is that correct
correct okay and then at the bottom you
identify lmfs correct it came back to me
yes okay when you say it came back you
you couldn't remember his name at the
start but then later remembered it
correct okay as you were writing out and
bringing These Memories Back yes okay
thank you
um
so is it fair to say that his ribs
were his ribs his chief complaint yes
and he did not offer any indication to
you of a head injury no
I have just one last thing I want to
look at and then I think we're done
so dizziness loss of balance Did You
observe anything like that no I was
monitoring for those things and didn't
see them blurred vision no ringing in
the ears no sensitivity to light no
sensitivity to sound no mood changes not
that I observed was he dazed or confused
no
um you talk about headache no
nausea no vomiting no fatigue uh not I
don't know if I asked him about that one
so not that I recall there okay got it
any speech problems not that I notice
and the jury has seen a picture of you
before okay sorry to inform you
um we have been talking about you
already and do you remember Mr Sanderson
taking a picture I do of you yes during
that first aid yes while we were at
Empire first aid yeah and
um
did you know at any time was he on his
phone and making a post about that
picture
I'm not sure I don't recall did you help
him put together a post at all no
no did you check his eyes carefully I
did yes we um assessed for maybe
basically pupil reactivity if when you
shine a light if they're constricting
and then dilating back out again
okay and you remember doing that his
word equal and reactive okay and that
what does that tell you if they're equal
and reactive
um it's just another test to see if
potentially there is a brain bleed
mostly
got it
um
I think that's that's all I have thank
you
thank you Mr Egan
Mr Bueller
I think the point of Defense exhibit of
your report is a little bit clearer the
one we have is a little less clear on
page three
what was that uh
exhibit number for defendant at which
part of it
first page
separate exhibit yeah 26 it's around
25 24a is the first page of the incident
with BC yeah they're slightly out of
order the supplemental report is 25 B
yes that's good that's what you're
looking for
you're thinking about it okay
are you qualified to diagnose TBI or
brain injury no I do not diagnose
you noted on your report that uh
there was uh under assessment the first
thing he wrote was mild disorientation
correct correct and then Android paying
right side
correct correct
and then
transport via toboggan to EFA that's
Empire first aid it is
then reassessment
disorientation lessened but the
disorientation was still
Apparent at the first aid station right
not by the time Mr Sanderson left you
know but before when he got there at the
first aiding station he had mild
disorientation I do not recall that
being down there
okay
and um
you did not believe
Craig Ramon the large male friend lmf
when he told you or told in your
presence that it was Gwyneth Paltrow who
had hit Terry from behind it seemed like
sort of an unbelievable statement at the
time
you know if that man appeared on the
scene that's strange similar
okay
um
and it was the supervisor that asked you
to write that report
you hand wrote
three weeks later correct correct okay
um was Terry Sanderson very appreciative
of your assistance that day yes I
remember him being very kind
yeah do you understand he still is very
appreciative of what you did I'm glad
glad I could help him
you said he was rattled on the hill
what is rattle oh well does rattled mean
disorientation that is my version of it
yes that is how I would present that
so is uh rattled or disorientation is
that a possible sign of a
concussion
not in the way that I was presenting it
but I can see how it could come off
that possible he could have had a
concussion because he was rattled
my tests we were coming out with no
but again I don't diagnose so down the
line someone else could come up with
something different someone who's
qualified to diagnose a concussion
correct
okay and you're not qualified to
diagnose it I do not diagnose
okay you encouraged Terry Sanderson to
go to the clinic correct I did
so your main goal was to stabilize them
and focus on him you you did not
investigate the Collision matters even
though Craig Ramon said
it was Gwyneth Paltrow who hit him from
behind
I did not chase that down though
he did not believe Craig Ramon
when I come up on a collision that one
party has gone from I'm not going to go
try and find that person it's pretty
impossible
unless it's someone's famous it could be
but it's sort of a hearsay thing at that
point
just give me a moment please
thank you Miss Smith that's all I have
hold on one second
thank you I just have one more sure
Miss Smith uh there was a question about
you being asked to write those
additional comments to your callback I
do uh
did you write those with any intention
of covering up anything that you you
knew about this accident no recovering
for Miss Paltrow because she's a
celebrity no
computer
just the opposite question when you
wrote those comments you were trying to
reveal that Ms palfro was involved in
this at least her name was mentioned
right I was just writing down what I
recalled okay thank you
okay you're excused but you may need to
be called back again so please don't
discuss the case with anyone and don't
watch the proceedings thank you
and I think he's out there so we'll have
to go grab him sure
all right
good afternoon Mr Graf if you could walk
right up here
and be sworn in as a witness
do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God thank you and take a seat in the
witness stand and then Begin by I guess
positioning the microphone and then
stating and spelling your name
I'm Steve Graf g-r-a-f-f
witness told me that he is thirsty do
you mind if I
I'm gonna drink
thank you
all right Mr Graf
um
thank you for being here we don't have
much time so you'll be quick
I first want to ask you whether you know
about a man named Mr Sanderson Terry
Sanderson I do and how do you know about
him
I know he was involved in a ski accident
at Deer Valley in February of 16. and he
is subsequently filed suit against
originally Deer Valley and Gwyneth
Paltrow and
um
how do you know about this
well I know about the accident
beginning the day of the accident and
been involved in it off and on for the
last six years okay and in what capacity
did you learn about this accident in
terms of professional life well my
professional life the day of the
accident
um
I spoke with Whitney Smith about it at
the end of the day
okay about the accident and what did you
learn from here what was your
understanding from your conversation
with her it was just end of the day work
and the Escape troll room as the patrol
comes in I'm usually around that area so
if they have questions about scheduling
just talk about the day many of those
type of things
and she was in the Empire first aid room
for
an extra long period of time so
questioned about that and she said yeah
the crazy thing is there was somebody
there that said that Gwyneth Paltrow was
involved
okay anything else that you understood
from your interactions with her that was
the end of any interactions
with that for a number of days okay with
end of interactions with Miss Smith yes
and what was your role your job at Deer
Valley at that time at that time I was
the ski patrol manager for Deer Valley
okay so you managed all of Miss Smith
and her colleagues making sure that
they're organized running the various
runs so that they can help people that
may be in trouble is that a good sort of
layperson that's a pretty good
description there were 70 ski patrollers
managed Staffing six different mountains
a number of different ski patrol
stations first aid rooms things of that
nature on a daily basis okay
and um
so after that assessment or sorry I
shouldn't say assessment keeps I was
saying that a bunch of Miss Smith uh the
LA that interaction with Miss Smith
uh did you have any other involvement in
um
trying to determine what had happened in
this Collision
not that day no it wasn't until
maybe a week to 10 days later that I saw
a instructor comment form come in
from Mr Christiansen and
he had been with Gwyneth Paltrow that
day and he had listed that she was
involved in a collision and so I reached
back out to Whitney and said hey there
might be some validity to that do you
mind giving us some more information on
that I I see because at first you it
wasn't clear that the claim about Miss
poucher was in fact true is that correct
no it was reported to me as just
somebody in the background saying it
there's no beautiful Bond woman at Deer
Valley must be Gwyneth Paltrow
okay
and um
did you do anything further to try and
figure out if anybody else on the
mountain Deer Valley employees knew
anything about the Collision not at that
time no okay
did you do anything later yes and when
was that
um
well a lot of things happen so
chronologically uh in the interests of
time I'll just kind of quickly go
through
how these things transpired as far as
I'm aware
um
so I mentioned that you know weeks 10
days after the accident noticed that
there was an instructor comment card
verified that Gwyneth was there asked
Whitney to
to follow up on that maybe a few more
statements about what happened that day
to add to her incident form
and then nothing for maybe a month or so
um sometime you know March April I
believe John gay the director of skier
Services received a letter from Mr
Sanderson
and in the letter if I remember
correctly he was concerned that the ski
responsibility code wasn't being
applied evenly because of Miss Paltrow's
celebrity status
and
he didn't mention in the letter
to John the director of skier services
the his employee yelled at him or
anything like that
in that particular letter there was
another follow-up letter similar content
weeks after that one
and then there was a request for
the contact information for Miss Paltrow
and when we first got that request we
complied
how it typically goes and it didn't go
any differently in this case is that we
reached out to Ms Paltrow and said Mr
Sanderson has requested your information
we're giving it to him we reached out to
Mr Sanderson said here's one of the
information we're giving it to her as we
would with any other case got it I see
and
um
what about any attempts to find well I
should back up and ask you some
foundational questions
in learning about this incident did you
ever hear about any ski patrollers
coming on the scene of the actual
Collision yeah that was later that we
started digging more into that
um
we supplied that information it wasn't
until
2019 I believe when we were served and
we really started digging into what had
happened and getting statements from
people and you know depositions and and
all of that and through that process we
dug a lot deeper into
I believe it was Christiansen that said
Escape troller came by the the scene
while they were still there and
everybody was present or mostly present
and so we looked into that and there
were two potential people that matched
the description I believe one of them
was on Empire one of them's on Flagstaff
bandana ski run connects both of them so
we reached out to both of those they
didn't recollect
um skiing by and asking anybody if they
needed help but that's not unusual
that you know any given day it's
probably more unusual on a ski run that
I don't ask somebody if they're okay you
know they're just very common occurrence
you go you see someone standing there
someone looking at a map someone picking
themselves up it's very common to say
are you okay and yep everything's okay
and then moving on and there's no no
documentation of that it's just routine
business I see and were there Patrol
logs that were connected with this I
think the jury's heard some description
of logs that are kept about who's on
which run in terms of the patrol people
is that right yes that's true there's um
logs on every mountain
and not every run is logged but if a
skeet troller goes down a run they come
back
they're like yep I did bandana at 11 24
and they would write that down and put
their initials on that
got it
um I believe I have those logs which are
defendants
exhibit 26a and
through C
and I don't believe that we have
published these so I would ask for
permission to publish these and admit
them how are they been marked for
identification defendants exhibit 26 A
through C
see yes okay any objection
there's no direction 26 A through C
defense exhibit is received
so I'll publish it it should be on that
screen for you Mr Graf do you see it uh
I do now okay is that the lawn we're
talking about
yes this is uh the Flagstaff Patrol log
this isn't the section I'm talking about
it's a two-page log okay so this is it
this is the 2026b is that the loggers do
I have to keep going so this would be
the Run log so you see where it says
opening run run check
um obviously a lot more runs are done
than that ski trailers typically do more
than a couple runs a day but they're
trying to make sure that all the runs
get checked so on this particular one as
it pertains to this we're looking for
bandana
and it's at the very top
and here at the top yep it looks like uh
11 40 and then there's another time and
a couple initials in there okay got it
and then just for the sake of
completeness then there's 26c I don't
know if that makes a difference here to
you is that was that part of your uh it
was this record or part of your attempt
to figure out who those patrollers were
yes this was part of us trying to get
all the information we could about this
and this 26c document does it offer
anything additional
um if I guess if you
can go zoom in go down zoom out yeah so
this is sweep so that's after the
accident so it doesn't offer anything
additional there
the page that you showed previously
has names of the people that were on the
mountain that day is that this page
that's that's page correct I see so at
the top there at the top here okay
yep so Caleb Jess Whitney and Tom were
there Steve Campbell was the snowmobiler
and he was better correctly I asked Tom
specifically because I saw his initials
in that log
but not only did I look at Flagstaff but
knowing that bandana is a connecting run
to Lady Morgan and Empire we looked at
those Patrol
controllers as well and ask them if
anybody on the mountain that day recalls
saying are you okay to some people on
bandana
and we didn't get any we didn't get any
affirmative response to that given your
experience with managing patrollers and
responding to various incidents if there
had been an incident where someone was
unconscious for a long time would you
expect to have heard about it
yes most definitely and would you expect
those patrollers to remember it if you
asked them a number of years later
yes and they did not they did not in
this case
okay even if the person wasn't
necessarily injured but wanted to ride
or had an equipment problem or if there
was anything other than no I'm okay it
most likely would have ended up in this
lock
I see and it does not you've reviewed
these and you don't see any
you don't see any indication of any uh
such event no okay
and um
do you know who Eric Christensen is I
think you mentioned him earlier I do
know who Eric christerson is and did you
ever receive a report that he had yelled
at Mr Sanderson
I believe that was in one of the claims
in the lawsuit but never never in our
investigation okay so you'd heard about
it in terms of claims in a lawsuit but
never aside from that
ever since no got it so there wasn't a
patroller that said hey we need to
respond to Mr Christensen he he's not
treating our customers properly
right and our investigation of all of
our employees that were involved or
could have been involved that's never
come up that question that no one ever
said yes that there was yelling or even
race voices or and if that had been
reported how do you respond to those
things how do you
um you know investigate an incident like
that maybe discipline employees
yeah I've been a leader and manager of
employees for nearly 30 years now and if
any one of my employees
verbally assaulted or gassed or yelled
at them or behaved in any way that was
inappropriate we would definitely take
action with that and no action was taken
against Mr Christensen no action was
taken no and I understand if I'm correct
you're no longer in that Patrol manager
position is that right that's right I
was the ski patrol manager and in 2000
and
17 it became the director of mountain
operations and in 2022 I'm the Vice
President of Operations okay so is it
fair to say you're familiar with how
Deer Valley responds to
employees that have
that misbehave or that engage in
behavior that um
is
inappropriate towards guests yes I'm
aware of that okay
and then what about and you're are you
aware of how Deer Valley deals with
celebrities on the ski slopes
I I am aware of how Deer Valley
deals with celebrities on the ski slopes
um and how how is that do they treat
them any differently than other people
no
that we don't there's no reason for Deer
Valley to really Deer Valley is a
company and broadly tell our employees
about when celebrities are at Deer
Valley the only time in my 29 years or
so at Deer Valley that I've known about
celebrities is when we think there might
be some disruption to our business right
like Paparazzi or things of that nature
um I can only think of two incidences in
that time frame that there was a reason
why we would want some of our employees
to know about celebrities being on the
mountain
you know if it was you know heads of
state or members of Congress or sitting
presidents or past presidents you know
with security details we're usually
informed of those things but not
celebrities
to your knowledge to Deer Valley
employees Executives anyone involved
with your Valley do anything to cover up
the facts of this case to protect
Gwyneth Paltrow absolutely not
and were you even aware uh
that Miss Paltrow was on the slopes that
day I wasn't aware of it until I read
the instructor comments
that
just happened to mention that my student
was Gwyneth Paltrow and was involved in
a collision
and I recalled that hey Whitney was on
an accident a week or so ago and
there was somebody there that said the
same thing so that's when it those two
pieces came together for me and does
Deer Valley have any position on what
occurred in terms of the Collision who
who hit who
no there's
um with the varying statements there's
different statements about what happened
and so we as a company don't have a
position on who's at fault
that's all my questions thanks
thank you Mr Egan
Mr Sykes judge I've not more than seven
minutes she went out the journey though
early tonight he
said
see you again nice to see you Mr Sykes
we know each other from other cases
don't we we know each other yes
um
this is the log that was referred to a
minute ago 26a can you see it there
I do
uh
19 or 9 58 A.M
skier assist what was that uh next word
can you read that uh
well knowing that was on Flagstaff
Mountain I'm going to say it's
Sidewinder okay Sidewinder is a run
there
next one is 10 36
lost
something boot is that right
it says lost Boulder bad boot yeah so
that's what I was saying skier has a bad
boot
on
was it bandana
that would be lost Boulder bad boot they
lost Boulder a bad boot
and that gets logged in
correct right
um
and uh
a skier Collision
on bandana
doesn't Merit a login
at let's say 11 55 A.M
a collision doesn't even mention a get a
mention
yeah that goes back to what I said
before that if it was a equipment like
bad boot or somebody needed an assist
like maybe they needed a ride down it
would get logged but if the people said
I'm okay it wouldn't okay at 1202 PM now
uh Whitney Smith says Whitney there
uh is in a possible 1050 is a collision
right
possible 1050 is an accident in action
okay and bandana okay
and she notes
skier Collision Collision disorientation
correct now you investigate these things
for Deer Valley is it your position
that maybe seven minutes just seven
minutes or so after that Collision
he's disoriented but at the time of the
Collision he's not disoriented is that
your position
I I don't have a position on that
well take one I mean five or seven
minutes later Whitney Smith
who has no skin in the game except she's
employed by you
okay no it's disorientation honor honor
report and she noticed it later by the
way as you noticed right and you're
trying to tell this jury
that just seven minutes before this
individual wasn't disoriented
is there a question there yeah that's
the question are you trying to tell the
jury that seven minutes before Terry
Sanderson wasn't disoriented when the
other two guys stopped by
who didn't log it
I wasn't trying to tell us anything got
a request yes
you may proceed Mr Sykes
do you remember the question no okay
are you telling this jury of the good
men and women of Summit County
that maybe five to seven minutes
after this Collision
it's noted here
I assume by Whitney Smith or someone
noted it
that there was a collision and there was
disorientation
and that five to seven minutes before
that there was no disorientation is that
what you're saying
I'm not saying that on this form at 1204
when he said there was a skier Collision
the person presented with disorientation
I don't know where you're getting the
five to seven minutes earlier what are
you referring well
the accident was logged the crash was
logged at 11 55.
by who
well it's in one of the records I think
it was Eric Christensen
11 55.
you weren't aware of that there's a time
frame there I know that at 1202 Whitney
was dispatched and I don't see the
screen anymore but I believe it was 1204
she was on scene well
uh
okay so Christiansen said he was on
senior that was right five minutes
before then and he didn't notice
disorientation
all right uh and your uh uh no
have you ever had a broken rib
yes it's pretty painful isn't it
incredibly very painful incredibly
painful have you ever had
four broken ribs four no all right
Terry
was diagnosed
at the VA with four broken ribs the very
next day
okay now is it reasonable and you've had
a long history in skiing with and with
Deer Valley
long and lustrous history right yes okay
do you think that a man has just had
four broken ribs four
okay
would tell
a ski patrol guy who came by that he was
okay
is that reasonable to you yes that's
reasonable I've four broken ribs I've
seen I've seen that happen
over and over again
over and over again people with four
broken ribs tell us ski patrol that
they're okay maybe not with four broken
ribs but
quite frequently people say they're okay
they want to be okay
okay
let me ask you
um
Pete would you find
me
okay now
you didn't see the crash did you no I
did not
and you have no personal knowledge of
how serious it was no I don't you're
aware that uh Terry Sanderson has a
witness
there's not even a close friend
just a meet-up buddy
that says
that Gwyneth Paltrow hit him in the back
you wear that I'm aware of the badass
okay
does that count for anything in your
opinion
part of all of this part of this
investigation uh
your Valley however takes no position
one way or the other on how the
Collision occurred
no there's differing
opinions or statements on what happened
but their family takes no position we
don't take any position now yeah
um
you don't give celebrities any
advantage no say no you're aware that
she paid almost nine thousand dollars
for two days to scheme you wear that I
believe I saw that somewhere in the
records I think it might be overly
inflated but somewhere in there that
doesn't sound unreasonable
okay now that's a lot of money to pay
for two days isn't it
it's all right Deer Valley cost a lot of
money
we can either recess now or if you just
have a few minutes of questioning you
could you could finish well
I think I hate to hold a jury Lake why
don't we recess and I'll finish tomorrow
all right
I have an objection
tomorrow why don't we address that at
after the jury's excused thank you
members of the jury we're going to
recess now until 9 A.M tomorrow morning
so remember my admonition not to talk
about the case with anyone not to do any
of your own investigation and if you
happen to look at the television or
listen to the radio or go online please
avoid or do avoid reading anything or
listening to anything about the case so
thank you hopefully we won't have a
storm in the morning
thank you you can step down
Mr
Mr Owens
yes yeah did you have something you
wanted to talk about
yes thank you
your honor the plaintiffs still have not
rested That was supposed to take place
Friday at the end of the day
I had Apple Martin Moses Martin and Brad
falchuk all ready to go this morning and
they were unable to testify
I as I understand it plaintiffs will not
oppose apple and Moses
having their deposition transcript read
into the evidence can we confirm
Mr Sykes that's that's that's correct as
long as our additions are added which
I've given counsel
you and Brad falchuk uh
still um
still haven't made a decision we may
need to read his transcript into
we have two full days tomorrow the court
hasn't made a decision about what
oh sorry
um Brad falchuk is the husband
with me and what decision do I need to
make about that I'm sorry we
you need to make a decision okay yeah
I'm just speaking through a mask which
makes it hard
um tomorrow Tuesday can I give my lineup
what's the lineup for tomorrow
starting with finish up Mr um
my objection
my objection to
we're already terribly behind just just
a minute Mr Grafton the room here
maybe you better run out and grab him
and make sure he's going to be here at
nine o'clock in the morning
somebody from the plaintiff side
so four of our Witnesses have been
thrown off just to let you know because
we had seven planned for today and
that's your choice Council
to throw them off
so
each side gets 50 of the trial time and
you're making a decision about how to
allocate that time
based on the assumption that plaintiffs
would be done on Friday and that's
between the two of you
okay I'm not complaining I'm just
putting this on the record and I so we
have
um
eight experts for tomorrow
most out of state Forum Wednesday
so we're we're lumping in now uh people
onto Friday excuse me Thursday morning
uh anyway you see that I've got in the
time for for Thursday morning it's two
hours and 7.75 uh to 2.75 hours or
something like like that that includes
closing arguments
wow that means
0.75 hours well Tuesday morning or
Thursday morning it's just an estimate
of what's available if we take up a lot
of time in out of jury hearings uh that
will get smaller and you're running an
excellent court but I'm just saying an
hour for closing on both sides means
essentially no evidence on Thursday
morning well you can start your CL you
can start your closings earlier than
that it just depends on when you rest
your case and when the plaintiff rests
their case
but your half time includes your closing
argument
see thank you for telling me that I
hadn't focused on that
so you envision the jury commencing
deliberations at about noon that would
be in a perfect world
okay and I understand
um you know we don't live in a perfect
world and so if if they have to be
charged a little bit later than that
they have to be charged a little bit
later than that thank you but that would
be in a perfect world all right so my
concern sorry to be so loud uh long on
this
we have Michael McMahan a physician
assistant Paul Bogger our ski expert
Urban
biomechanical expert and Stephen Edgley
our neurorehabilitation expert
uh they are not flexible
so my concern with having Steve Graf
come back tomorrow morning
is
um
that it's going to throw off
these folks that are not flexible okay I
would rather Steve Graf come back for
instance Thursday morning so that we can
get our our experts who are time sure so
you've got an expert that's ready to go
at 9am in the morning
so Michael mccahan is actually not our
expert so I may have misspoken he was
the treating physician assistant at the
InstaCare and he is ready at 9am yes
okay all right well you know I'll
probably only have about
10 to 12 minutes to finish this up why
don't we wait but I'd rather just get it
done I realize that but we do have some
professionals that we need to make some
accommodation for and so why don't we
wait with Mr Graf's completing Mr Graf's
testimony until we can fit it in
sometime a little bit later maybe later
tomorrow or if you want to schedule him
for a specific time we can do that as
well the Sheep graph has flexibility to
show up anytime
he doesn't remember the uh treating
Terry Sanderson it's it's just a record
review and there's very little he would
have to offer because he has no
recollection of ever seeing the
plaintiff I think he will be sure so why
don't you speak with Council for Deer
Valley and find out when you can
schedule Mr Graf one makes sense to to
schedule him can you give him some
blocks of time when he could schedule
that yes I mean so if we can hold him to
10 minutes we can live with it in the
morning tomorrow morning yes what we
can't live with is it's 10 minutes and
now it's two hours well are you gonna do
another 10 or 15 of redirect
James is on it probably not
uh I will commit to 10 minutes all right
then we'll call him in the morning
okay so when are we getting back in the
morning and we'll even try we'll start
as soon as the jury is here if they're
all assembled at 10-2 we'll start
I've seen so many sidebars
foreign is that a compliment or a
criticism
you're working very hard judge thanks
anything else Council
right so come early the jury has been
asked to be here at 8 45 if they're all
assembled we'll start
up then okay
thank you thank you
thank you give you your time remaining
all right I'll give the time that you've
taken and my anticipated time remaining
right thank you that'd be helpful